- Hello, and welcome to
a very special episode
of Trash Taste podcast.
I am your host for
today, once again, Garnt.
- And you're always the
host, where's the guest.
- Joining me today is
of course the boys CDawg
and The Anime Man.
- You've never called us that.
- The Hentai boy now?
- Why are you so nervous, Garnt?
(laughs)
- He's trying not to seem--
- Are you nervous perhaps
because of the person
who is sitting next to you right now?
- So we have first here on Trash Taste.
We have a 2D guest with us today.
- Hello!
- Looking wonderful
in your attire.
- I know right.
- Oh, thank you.
- Would you like to introduce
yourself to the world?
- Sure, okay.
Hello everyone.
I'm Calliope Mori
and I'm from the first
generation of hololive English.
Nice to meet you all and
thanks for having me.
- Yeah, of course.
- Yay!
- See I wanted you to introduce yourself
because we've been
pronouncing your name wrong
this entire time.
- As most people do, as most people do.
- Okay, to be fair though.
In my defense,
it is rather confusing because
like the English name right,
is Calliope.
- Right.
But when you type it in
Katakana like in Japanese,
it's Calliope.
- That's right.
- Right.
So I'm just like, which one is it?
- Well, actually the truth,
is I actually never thought about that.
(laughs)
- I never thought about that,
there were many things--
- So I'm like,
looks like which one's the law?
Which one's the real law?
But now we know it's both.
- Yes indeed.
- Yeah.
- So like, where did that name come from?
- Well, actually it has various
meanings, believe it or not.
So Calliope is actually
the Greek muse of poetry,
epic poetry.
- Oh, alright.
- And as you know, I do dabble just a bit
in the Sick Nasty rhyme.
(laughs)
Creation of flames et cetera.
- Is that how you are flirting with us?
- Listen--
- The fire speed burn.
- I'm just trying,
I'm just trying to get used
to the weird things people...
People say things in such
strange ways these days.
And I just, I don't, I'm not
used to it yet, I'm sorry.
- Well, yeah, because like,
this is not only a first for
Trash Taste having a 2D guest,
but I think we are kind
of making YouTube history
in a sense, because I do believe...
- This is the first time 2D
and 3D have joined together.
- Right.
- Connor's fucking dying right now.
(laughs)
- Its so funny 'cause the
way that we're filming this,
Garnt literally cannot move
or else it will fuck up everything.
And Garnt looks so fucking nervous.
He's like, "Yes and
today we have, the guest"
- Are you sure it's not because I'm death?
Cat wink.
- That too.
That too but also the fact
that like I do believe
that we are probably one of the first
known hololive YouTube
channels to feature--
- [Garnt] Like a hololive member
- Yeah, like do a split collab.
Like official collab
with a hololive member.
- Well, I think this is, well this...
I'm not sure about the Japanese side,
but this is definitely like
the English side of things.
- [Joey] Oh yeah, yeah.
- Actually this is the first
collab where I've seen hololive
do other things with people
outside of hololive so.
- 'Cause I mean, how long
is hololive EN been around
right now?
- Well, you know it like,
it's been three years
but it's been about a month.
(laughs)
- In YouTube years--
- Believe it or not.
- In Youtube years it's three years.
Because like three months on
YouTube feels like three years.
- Gosh, that's sure is how
it feels, I tell you what.
- It has just been a month, hasn't it?
Like just over a month and it's a drag.
Oh my God, it feels like it
was like the beginning of 2020
the hololive English launch.
- Yeah, right?
That's that's why I was..
That's why it's just shocking to me
how fast and how powerful
just the hololive English
side of things was growing,
because I mean like,
you don't even have to be a
hololive like simp or anything,
or like even follow VTubers
and you'll see people like
re-tweeting memes and shit,
all VTubers and the
hololive members so it--
- I do see a lot.
- Yeah right?
- And I don't care.
- Yeah.
(laughs)
- It's lovely to meet you by the way.
- Lovely to meet you too, it's fine,
it's fine, I get it all the time.
- I think it's really cool,
I've seen you get smashed on stream,
that was really entertaining.
- Now wait a minute.
Now wait a minute.
Everyone says that, but
listen, here's the thing.
- Okay, okay, okay--
- You guys haven't seen anything yet.
(laughs)
- Everyone likes to say things like,
"Ah, look at, look at Calliope, so funny,
"she's drunk, ha ha ha,"
like it's a big, funny joke,
but if you want to see me
drunk, just wait a bit.
- To be fair I've seen the stream
where you'll smash down the spirytus--
- Okay well the spirytus was
a different situation, listen.
- I'm totally unfamiliar
with everything pretty much.
- You gotta explain,
like I'm five kinda...
- Would you guys explain
and especially you
being the professional death god hololive.
- Sure.
(laughs)
Anytime.
- Why you laughing?
- It's totally real, death god's real.
Please fully explain everything to me
'cause I'm a total new,
but I don't know anything.
I literally died don't.
I've watched one of your streams
where you played DOOM Eternal.
I thought you were a bit bad
at it and I'm not gonna lie--
(babbles)
- You got a pro gamer here just--
- Just saying.
(laughs)
- Now, listen, listen
to me, here's the thing.
Killing with a PS4
controller is much different
than using a scythe, okay.
(laughs)
Just here me out, just here me out, man.
- I'll take that, I'll take
that excuse, I'll take it.
- But I'm getting better, I'm trying.
Every time that I play,
I get just a bit better.
And I must say I would quit
but the thing is it's
such a rush, you know.
Reminds me of the old days
when I wasn't off hiatus.
You feel me?
- [Connor] Right.
- Is that why you play DOOM, Connor?
- Yeah too from my old days.
(laughs)
- Back in school when I was--
(babbles)
- Oh my God.
- Okay, so let's hear like..
Explain to Connor--
- I genuinely, I know very little only--
- No, no, and I'm sure there's a number
of people watching this episode right now.
(babbles)
- Why is there an anime girl
sitting in the seat, right?
- So like in your own words, Calli,
like explain what hololive is
and explain what Vtubing is.
- Sure, okay.
Well, let's see.
I can go ahead and start
with, with Vtubing, I suppose,
because hololive is a group that Vtubes.
So I suppose I'll go ahead and start
from the very beginning.
So a virtual YouTuber is
basically just that a YouTuber
that is not necessarily a
human necessarily I guess.
Necessarily a fictional--
- Or 3D?
- A fictional 3D.
(laughs)
I mean--
- 3D human.
- Sometimes they're 3D.
- I mean I'm certainly
real as far as I can tell.
But essentially, I'm I
guess what many people say
is a cute anime girl, right?
(laughs)
I am a cute anime girl.
- In lay man terms--
- When you gonna help me out?
Help me like this man.
(laughs)
- I am a cute anime girl.
And I do various things like I stream
and I suppose more specific to
me is that I also make music.
So yeah, that's kind of, I guess my thing.
- And you make some good music.
- Thank you.
- Yeah, yeah, yeah.
- I appreciate that.
- You are the god of spit
and fire that's for sure.
- Thank you.
- However, you refer to it as.
- Whatever you said before--
- Spitting flames.
- Spitting flames, that's it.
- Spitting flames
is what it is.
I'm pretty sure that
that's the name for it.
- Yeah, so I'm gonna jump right into it.
What's your opinion of simps?
(laughs)
- Wait, I thought we were
gonna ask do VTubers poop?
Is that a real thing?
- Oh yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah.
- Can you ask that?
Is it true?
- Do tootie anime girls poop?
- That's a wonderful question.
The truth is I don't actually know.
- Oh, didn't expect that.
Alright, cool.
Alright, I'm sorry, back to your question.
- You don't know, wait, hold on,
you don't know--
- Well here's the thing,
I don't know about anime girls or VTubers,
but I am death and death does not have to,
so I can't actually answer your question.
- I was gonna say like, do you
not know as in like you don't
or you don't know as in
like, it just comes out
without you knowing it.
(laughs)
- Like you're not even
aware that it's out.
(laughs)
- I don't think it's that one.
- Sorry back to your question.
- But yeah, what's your opinion on simps?
What's a VTubers's opinion on simps?
- You mean shrimps?
- Shrimps.
- Oh yes, that's what
the kids call it now.
- I think that that's
what Gura calls them.
- Yes.
I think that is the term
that humans today are using
for supporters, avid supporters.
I don't really, I don't know much--
- That's a nice way of putting it.
(laughs)
- So generous really--
- Well see--
(laughs)
- All I know is that sometimes in chat,
when I'm streaming they
throw rainbows at me
and I tell them to stop,
but then they keep doing it.
And the more that I tell them to stop,
the more that they continue to do it.
And I still don't really
know how to handle it,
to be honest.
But I think everyone is very well-meaning
and I'm happy for the support--
- I mean, I've seen the clip
of all those like Canadians,
like blue lives with the red super chats.
- It sure did happen huh.
(laughs)
- And it's probably gonna happen again.
Let's be real.
- I suppose you're right huh.
- So what I gotta ask
is like when hololive English
got announced, I don't like...
On my end of things, and
I've been following hololive
since kind of the beginning of the year.
I had no idea how big hololive
English was going to become.
Were you expecting the response
or like your fellow hololive
English cast members,
were you guys expecting
the response that you got?
- Well, it's interesting
because I actually,
we talked about this many times.
We actually had no idea how
we would be received, right?
Because it's not like the five of us
are the first English speaking girls
that have done work with hololive, right?
I mean, there are several hololive girls
that are able to speak
pretty good English.
So we weren't sure because no...
I suppose, how should I say this?
It's been difficult to
estimate, I suppose,
how well in English, English group of--
- Audience?
- Yes, exactly.
An English group of VTubers
would appeal to an
English speaking audience
because those who came before
us have done well of course.
But it's hard to tell
because we're the first,
mainly English speaking, right?
So we basically had no idea
is what I'm trying to say in
my long winded explanation
which makes absolutely no sense
because I'm a bit of a
scatterbrain everyone knows this--
- So like did you, like all
the hololive English members,
did you guys like meet beforehand,
like before all the reveals are happening?
- Nope.
- Oh, so you met each other,
like after you debuted?
- Oh, no, we met before we debuted.
But this has been...
We were working together
for a very long time
beforehand, right?
And kind of getting to know each other
and I technically, yes, I
got to meet the other girls.
But before that we were
all just kind of shoved
into the same room and it was like,
"Hello, nice to meet you.
"All of you, you are my teammates."
See how well it worked out.
- Which is so weird, 'cause
like that's the equivalent
of like getting a bunch of
anitubers you've never met
being like, "Alright, you're
all starting a podcast
"from tomorrow."
- It's like, "What, no."
(laughs)
- Exactly, well, it turned out okay
because all of the other
girls are very laid back
and we all have personalities
that work really well with each other.
And it's never weird, we
all like each other a lot.
So that's cool.
I suppose we just got lucky.
Maybe, maybe that's what it is.
We just got super lucky.
- I think so from like, from the...
From what I've seen like all
the hololive English members,
they seem to work well--
- Yeah they work, you guys
seem to work well together
and you guys seem
to have like very distinct
personalities as well.
- Yeah I know.
- Yeah.
(laughs)
- What what'd you think of this Connor?
- It's good.
(laughs)
I feel like the--
- I think you should be the one
who is needs to like lead
on with the question.
- Why, why would I?
You guys are the simps right?
- Well no because you got no...
Because you're the one right now
who's representing everybody
who wants to know more
about hololive and like VTubers--
- Like what don't you know, about VTubers?
- Everything, I want to know is it...
When you were started off streaming,
was there any streamers out there,
anyone who, that you
kind of really enjoyed
who might've given you some
inspiration to start Vtubing?
- Well, to be honest,
I actually didn't know
anything about Vtubing
before I got into it, right?
But of course I started looking
up to my senpai, I suppose.
And mostly just other members of hololive,
I would say, yeah.
- Did you have to do
like a lot of research
before you really like debuted?
Just like make sure you
knew what you were doing.
- Well, it certainly wasn't required,
but this is the way that I am.
I get a little obsessed sometimes.
So to that say that before my debut,
I didn't go watch maybe every single video
that I could find of my supplier
of VTubers doing things.
If I said that I didn't do
that, that that would be a lie.
It would be untrue, it would be false
because I did, I definitely did that.
- Are you able to name,
like any specific hololive members
that you like, especially enjoy
'cause I'm sure I mean, you
know, it goes without saying,
I'm sure you enjoy everybody, right?
But like who especially, do
you enjoy, like personally?
- Ah, let's see, hmm...
Good question.
Well, I really always looked up
to probably a lot of the
musical senpais, right?
So for example, Azuki, and Suisei senpai
and also Watame senpai.
- Do you know who any of those are?
- It's like when people talk
to me about animator actors.
They're like, "Yeah, I
love this animator actor."
I'm like, "You just said
all the same names."
I'm not trying to be like racist,
but like, they always
sound the same to me.
I'm so dumb, I'm like a Neanderthal,
it just goes out, I'm sorry.
- It's no worries at all, I understand.
- Oh then here's the thing, right?
As a hololive member,
who is a hololive member
that you can convincingly
say Connor would get into?
- Yeah that's a good question.
- As a Neanderthal--
- As someone who hasn't
watched any VTubers--
- My favorite streamer is Tyler1.
Do you know Tyler1?
- Yes, I'm familiar.
- Fantastic.
- Believe it or not I am.
- Is there a Tyler1
equivalent in hololive?
- Gosh.
Well, let's see.
It depends, I need to ask you first.
What kind of content do you enjoy?
- That's a broad question.
- No it's a quite a broad question.
Do you like...
Well, for example, do you like...
Do you like things like game play?
Do you like FPS game play or--
- Yeah, yes sir, yeah I do.
- Okay, do you like chaos--
- He's a hardcore gamer.
- Do you like chaotic people?
- Yeah, I love chaotic people, I like--
- Then you should watch my
friend, Amelia, Amelia Watson.
- I think yeah, I think
that'd be good for you.
- She's very--
- She's got a lot of chaotic energy.
- She's a bit of a toxic gamer.
(laughs)
- That is Conner down to a tee.
- I should have just said toxic gamer--
- Yes then Amelia would
be perfect for you.
- Damn, yeah, 'cause I said on one podcast
that I was going to watch VTubers
and every episode since they'd been like,
"So which ones did you watch, Connor?"
And I'm like, "I don't
know where to begin."
I don't know, do I just watch a stream?
I don't know, like where do I find them?
- I mean, what...
Well, at least with me,
all I did was I just
found one that kind of...
I watched a couple until one
just kind of clicked with me
where I'm like, "Oh, okay,
"I can watch another clip
of this particular VTuber."
And then you just keep
watching more and more clips.
And then you go back and
watch some of the VODs.
And then you're like, "Alight,
"who did they play with the most?"
- There's like several
layers to this, right?
And like the top layer of the rabbit hole
is just finding like
this random Twitter clip
that appears in your timeline
and like, "That's pretty funny."
- I see clips with the dog all the time.
- Oh Korone.
- Korone senpai.
- Then like the second layer I would say
is like getting some random
YouTube recommendations,
like certain clips.
- I do, I get a lot of those.
- Because trust me, you
watch one VTuber clip
and your recommended is just all VTubers.
- Yeah, exactly.
- Ah yes.
- It's like, I don't know what it is
about VTuber clips that just...
They just seem like they're designed
to take over the YouTube algorithm.
'Cause you watch one
and then your feed is suddenly
all like full of them.
And then you're like,
"Hm, this clip sounds
kind of interesting."
And then you watch some and you're like,
"Huh, that VTuber kinda clicks," you know?
- Like, "Oh, that clip was interesting.
"Let me go watch the whole VOD now."
That's always how it works.
Alright yeah.
No, but I reckon, I reckon
Amelia would be best.
- Okay.
- Sure, I probably--
my recommendation would be
watch her debut stream first,
very first stream that she ever did.
So that she can introduce
herself to you, et cetera.
And then after that you
can just dive right in.
- Although to be fair,
I've seen a lot of the hololive members
who have changed greatly
since they debuted.
- It's true but that's
part of the fun I think.
- It's like seeing
character development, IRL.
But like, I gotta ask
you, how nervous were you
for your debut stream?
'Cause I assume you didn't
have any streaming experience
before that.
And then going from like
no streaming experience,
like stream to such a large audience--
- How many people were in
your debut stream again?
- I think that the peak
number of viewers was 60,000.
- Jesus Christ!
- Holy shit!
- How'd you go from zero to 60 K.
- Yeah.
- In a day.
- I mean I've, I think we
all had like kind of...
- I don't think...
We've never reached those
numbers in live streaming terms.
- Right, I mean, I've had like
livestreams that were big,
but nothing like that and
especially not in my first time.
Is it kind of overwhelming
to have to jump into this
and start off with such a big amount?
'Cause like I said, we've
all had really gradual rises
over the years.
Is it daunting, even as a death god?
- Right, well, see, here's
the thing when your death,
no one really sees you, right?
I mean, for the most
part, maybe you do see me,
but not as I am now.
- I think there's people you kill and doom
see it coming for...
(laughs)
- Well I would hope so.
- Oh they're the purgers.
- Oh there it is, there's
the guy, he's gonna kill us.
(laughs)
- Exactly.
Well, I mean, if you
think about it that way,
going from yes, no one
ever seeing me at all
to suddenly all of these eyes on me,
yeah, I mean it's a little scary.
Yeah, for sure, I definitely
was kind of losing my mind
a little bit, to be honest,
I was going a little nuts.
But I wasn't going to show anyone that,
especially not when I started turning
into a PowerPoint slide show,
because my computer wasn't
strong enough to handle
all the applications
open at the same time.
That's when I especially
started freaking out.
So yeah, it was very nerve wracking,
but people were very kind and
I was surprised about that.
I went in expecting an
immediate barrage of hate
and no kindness at all,
believe it or not because--
- That is the internet.
- That is the internet yeah.
- It's really pretty good at that.
- And as death, I'm prepared for that.
- I mean though, that's good though,
that you were at least positively received
in front of 60,000 people.
- So what made death
wanna become a streamer?
That's what I wanna know.
- What a great question.
- Sometimes you just get
tired of slaying people, man.
I tell you what, I mean...
- I feel like I'm asking Dora
why she keeps asking me questions.
You know what I mean?
It's like I know it's an
obvious thing, but like Dora--
- Why do you keep exploring?
- Dora, what's up with that like why--
- There's nothing more left to explore?
- Dora you know what that is.
It's the number four Dora.
Don't ask me these stupid
questions, you know, I mean...
- You know you have to turn left.
(laughs)
- Alright, it's the best number indeed.
Sorry, I got hung up on--
- Sorry I know I
interrupted you, I'm sorry.
- It's okay, it's okay.
I mean...
What's the question?
I'm kidding.
- What made you want to become a streamer?
- Right.
Yeah, so...
I really just kind of got...
I mean, as I mentioned, yeah,
I got tired of slaying people,
but also I had this feeling that maybe
if I had more eyes on...
I could have more eyes on
maybe the things that I make,
like music, et cetera,
because slaying people is
real fun, don't get me wrong.
I love it but--
- But spitting bars is fun alright.
- Exactly, if there's a different way
that I can slay people I'd like to try it.
And honestly, I have more
fun doing that, so yeah.
- You kill people by setting
their house on fire, right,
with all those flames--
- Exactly I kill them with the base.
- Your lyrical slang.
- So in terms of music,
do you do like everything
on your own as well?
Like, are you experiencing
all like the beat making
and all that?
'Cause I'm fucking garbage at all of that.
- Yeah.
Connor's like mega monkey brain
when it comes to music so--
- So yeah, I saw that you
did a rap competition, right?
I think one of the people
who got to the final
was someone that we've done raps for.
- Like Joshua.
- Yeah, yeah, a little remix
competition for my debut song.
- And I saw DJ Joe was in the trials--
- Yeah DJ Joe was in there as well.
- And, we've done raps before, but I...
So Joey actually you write your own raps
and perform them, right?
- Yes.
- I'm so fucking terrible,
I have no rhythm that I
have to ask him to write it,
and then I have to ask
him to record him doing it
and then I'll mimic it.
- Oh really?
- Yeah, I literally--
- You just basically got
a cheat sheet unlike--
- Because even if they give me the rap,
I actually don't know how to rap it.
Like I'm reading these words--
- You don't know the flow of it.
- Yeah, I read it like
a businessman reading,
like an accounting page,
you know, how do I do that?
How do I get better 'cause
I'm terrible at all of this.
- Well, I mean, interestingly enough,
everyone starts out
being F wording terrible.
Sorry, I really shouldn't curse anymore.
- You can curse on this
show, it's alright.
- I can, is it okay?
- Oh it's totally good.
- They won't get mad?
Okay, hold on.
(clears throat)
- She's gonna say it, she's gonna say it.
(laughs)
- I can't do it on command.
It'll come out, it'll come out--
But really, everyone starts
out bad, that's the truth.
Even I started out very
bad back in the day.
Back in the day but...
And that's why I was afraid
to start rapping actually,
because I had already gotten so good
at killing folks, right?
- Right, right, why change
your danger alright?
- Yeah, exactly, I mean, I'm
already good at this, right.
So why would I switch to
something that I'm not good at
or that I know I'm not skilled at.
But I was so inspired, I suppose,
by multiple people mostly
in the underworlds rap scene, I would say.
Is very low key, and as you
would expect underground.
They really inspired me a lot.
And I decided, well, I
might as well give it a try.
So I did.
And over time you get better.
And even listening back to my old things.
Yeah they're terrible, they're
garbage, absolute garbage.
Like there's no, there's
no sugarcoating there.
But I mean,
the advice that I give is
always the same cliche stuff
that you hear all the
time, but it worked for me.
Listen, you just gotta keep going
even if you suck and if
you suck, you keep trying.
Because if you quit, when you suck,
that's a real shame because
you stopped doing it
and you suck, you still suck forever.
- Yeah, I mean, at this...
I think the best advice
you can give anyone
to like learn any skill
set is just to do it
and just to try and--
- Just keep trying.
- Yeah, it's true when it comes to rapping
and it's true when it comes
to making YouTube videos--
- I mean, cause like...
I definitely like the first couple of raps
that I did for like Josh
or like any other like
collaborator that I did like...
I look back and I'm just like, "Man,
"that was shit."
- That's what I mean like five minutes
after I make anything I'm like,
"God, that's shit!"
- But the latest stuff I did
I was like, "My boy's spitting bars."
- I'm still trying--
- That's the kind
of fire though.
- I'm still trying to make people forget
that I once took parts in like the...
What was it, the Anitube?
- Oh, can we show you Garnt rapping?
- No!
Don't do that!
- Is that something...
Is that a real thing that I can watch?
- Okay, yeah, so this is
like a community thing
that we used to do every year where...
It's called the Anitube Cypher--
- That's what it's called.
- And basically it's like--
- The Anime Cypher.
- Yeah, the Anime Cypher.
So like one person would find a beat,
like a creative commons beat,
and then spit like an eight
bar or a 16 bar or whatever.
And then they would tag another Anituber
to be like, alright, now you
have to like respond and--
- Well I'm fucking leaving if
we're getting this out now.
- And so like...
When was this?
Like you did it like, well, 2018?
- 2017 I think.
- 2017 or 2018, forgot which one it was.
But that was the year
where like the most amount
of anitubes did.
And of course, Garnt got
tagged like 60 million times.
And so he joined in and...
He's bars though.
(laughs)
- It's awful.
- Were they fire?
Were they flames?
- No, they weren't.
- I bet they were.
- They weren't even an ember.
They were not even oh...
(mumbles)
- I'll be the judge of that.
- I'm a leave it.
- You can't move Garnt.
- I'm a head out.
I'm a head out.
- You're trapped, I
won't allow you to move.
- I'm a head out right now.
- No!
- Here we go!
- Get it out!
- Ha!
- Wait, Garnt, Garnt.
- Sh!
- Here we go.
♪ If we're being Asian ♪
(laughs)
- We'll link it in the description as well
just in case you wanna
hear the whole thing.
- Flames.
- My favorite bar--
- My favorite bar was from...
What was it?
It's like, it's that motherfucking tea.
(laughs)
- I know, I've wiped
that rap from my memory
and I fucking hate everyone
for mentioning that now.
- We all did a rap, right?
We should do a bonus video
where you react to all of our raps.
I think that would be fun.
- That would be fun, yeah, yeah, I think
we should definitely do it.
- Yeah, that sounds cool.
I'm down.
- I hate you all.
I hate you all right now.
- I gotta ask just the death god.
Do you have a favorite meme?
- Me-me?
- A meme, a me-me, a meh-meh,
whichever you prefer
pronunciation, I don't wanna die.
- Gosh!
(laughs)
It's okay--
- Can you kill me right now.
I just wanna die.
- Everyone does.
- I'm sorry, I had to do that to you.
This is like the parent pulling
out like the baby photos
with the dick out.
It's like, "Look how tiny it is dick was."
(laughs)
Sorry, sorry, yeah.
Shouldn't talk about unsightly things
around the death god, sorry.
- Oh, it's fine, you can
talk about whatever you like.
- [Connor] Oh, okay.
- Yeah its cool,
no problem.
- Were you
like nervous to debut our first song?
- Oh yes, definitely, I...
Well, because you all can tell I have...
I'm very different sounding, right?
I have a very interesting style.
It's kind of off the world--
- You certainly have
a distinct like voice,
like rapping voice, definitely.
- For sure, so yeah, I was pretty nervous,
I didn't know how people were
going to receive it, right?
So that was a big worry.
I thought that there would be
a lot of backlash against it,
for whatever reason.
I also just hold myself to a
really, really high standard.
So listening back to my
rap again, I was like,
"Is this really any good?"
I don't know.
- To be fair though, you
set it up really nicely
because like, you kind of like hinted,
like during your story.
'Cause I remember
I was watching your debut
stream again yesterday
and you debuted your first
song on the debut stream.
And like, I think the way you
like kind of set yourself up
being like, you know,
"Oh, I'm just like, you
know, trying this rap thing."
And then the song starts
and people are like,
"Alright, well, you
know, she sounds nervous,
"I'm not gonna expect
like the most amazing rap,
"but it's still going to be cute anyway."
And then three seconds later,
you're just like
speeding, like insane flow
and I'm just like, "Holy shit!"
- Oh yeah, I mean you gotta
lower those expectations first.
Am I right?
Oh gosh.
- Exactly.
- Like if you had psyched yourself up
being like, "Yeah, yeah,
"I can rap."
- I'm the shit.
- That's hustling.
- Yeah, then it would
have been like, alright.
But I think you went into
it really nicely, okay.
- Thanks.
- Okay yeah, so I wanna know
as like a person who
also likes his rap music,
like, do you wanna like
give any shout outs
I guess, or like more like your--
- Influences or anything like that.
- Yeah the influences basically
like Japanese or like Western rap, right?
- Oh, sure, yeah, absolutely.
Well, let me think about it
because a lot of my favorites
are definitely under
the radar, I would say.
- Who would you say is
like the most well-known?
- Ah, gosh.
- Out of your favorites.
- In terms of like the
Japanese rap, I wonder.
I feel like...
- I mean, I think on the
broader scale of things
like to a Western audience,
not a lot of people know
a lot of Japanese rappers,
right?
- Right yeah.
- Like I'd say probably the
most well-known Japanese rapper
might be like Shing02.
- Yeah, yeah, yeah, of course.
- Yeah, who did like...
Do you know Shing02?
- I don't know, I do not know Shing02.
- Okay, you know, the
Samurai Champloo opening?
- Oh okay.
(laughs)
- He's the guy who did all this stuff
with Nujabes basically.
- You gotta explain things
to me in anime terms.
If it's not in anime terms,
I probably wouldn't get it.
- He's the guy who did
the Samurai Champloo.
- [Garnt] Okay, okay.
- So he's probably like
the most well-known
in like the Western anime
community maybe, but like...
'Cause I don't even know
a whole lot of Japanese
underground rap either.
But like what about like Western rappers?
- Oh, let's see.
I feel like all the Western
rappers that I like are very...
How do I say?
Very obvious sort of like...
- [Connor] Like 2pac?
- Of course--
(laughs)
- Yeah, well, of course.
But like my favorite is of course Eminem
which is the very obvious answer.
- I'm white, yeah.
- Kind if like, "I know that one."
- I know that one.
- Every white guy when you ask
them what their favorite is,
I love Eminem, man.
- That's exactly what I mean.
- Exactly,
yes, and of course Snoop Dogg.
- Oh yeah, of course.
- I like his memes.
- Yeah, you do get some
quality memes from that man.
I'm I right?
- Is that the (laughs) pronunciation?
- I thought that that's what it was.
Is that not what it was?
- I thought it was when I was like 10.
- Oh, okay, how was the
right way to say it?
- Memes.
- Me-mes.
- Meme, me-mes?
- It's memes.
- I'm getting mixed signals here, hold on.
- Okay I'm sorry.
(mumbles)
- Alright, I think I get it. Memes.
- There you go.
- Noted.
Thank you for teaching me.
- Then do you have your...
Do you have a favorite Calliope meme?
- Wow, I've seen so many
of them floating around.
- Do you hang around on
like the hololive subreddits
and everything like that?
Do you see--
- Oh yes,
I check them, yeah for sure.
Yeah, I don't react or
anything, but I'm watching.
I'm watching you guys.
- Then everyone in the subreddit is like,
"Alright stop it boys."
- They're like,"Ah shoot."
- We're gonna get
to the pressures, print up
and get the fresh memes.
- And then there are plenty they're like,
"Ah shit, oh fuck, oh no."
(laughs)
- Let's see.
There is one.
I mean, I like a couple
of the reaction images.
There's one that I always remember
where like they turned my face red
and they put lights in my eyes.
And they like shoot out.
- Oh yeah.
- And it's really quite
scary and frightening.
And I'm like, "I like that."
- Is that the one with
like the screen or--
- Is that the like deep fried meme or--
- Yeah, that's the one.
Yeah I like that kind of stuff.
Yeah, that's good.
- So like you do like a lot
of types of streams, right?
I mean, you have seen do
you like drinking streams
and obviously DOOM and just Q and A's.
What's like your favorite type of stream
to like, kind of do
and what's kind of like
some of the favorite content
that you've made so far.
- Well, and that's a tough one.
Recently, the only time
that I have to play games
is when I stream.
So those are always quite
fun because I get to relax
and play a video game with
chat, which is good but...
Let's see.
I also really like the
streams where I can just talk
'cause it's fun just talking to chat.
You're talking about what's
going on with me, et cetera.
I never really run out
of things to talk about
which is something that I
always think is going to happen.
I always think, "Oh man, I didn't come up
"with some kind of outline.
"I don't know what I'm gonna do.
"I don't know what's gonna happen
"if I have nothing to talk about."
- That's literally this podcast.
- Yeah, exactly.
Somehow, some way,
I always come up with
things to talk about.
I don't know how it happens, it just does.
And then if I crack open a
bottle of wine, it's even better.
- Yeah, exactly, I mean like
people always wonder like,
"Why do you guys like drink
so often on the podcast?"
Because otherwise we'd just be like...
- I feel like, well yeah,
we haven't drank that much.
- We haven't drank that much recently
but I feel like anytime...
I don't know why.
Anytime that you stream and
you like drinking alcohol,
people are always afraid that...
People will go like mum
mode where they're like,
"Oh, you seem like you're
drinking a bit too much."
- You better watch yourself.
- [Connor] Are you drinking
enough water?
(laughs)
- It's like, "Yes mother I am."
- It's like glad you guys care, you know?
But don't worry, we can handle our drink.
- I get a lot of people
telling me I got hydrate.
I know.
- Alcohol is hydration.
- Exactly, I mean it is.
- It's a food.
- Yeah sure.
That's how it works, for sure.
Yeah, that's definitely how it works.
So keep drinking and don't stop, please.
- When I'm thirsty, I
just drink more wine.
(laughs)
- Okay so like you
obviously watch like all,
you're fellow hololive members, right?
But is there any non hololive
YouTubers you like watching?
- Ah, that's a great question.
Let's see.
Oh, there are plenty of indies
that I just casually go and
check out every once in a while
I would say.
But for the most part,
the VTubers that I really enjoy,
like their content, et cetera,
I would have to say are musicians.
So I check out their music
and that kind of thing.
Or like watch their shows and concerts.
I actually don't watch a ton
of actual streams I guess,
because I'm just very...
I'm very busy.
I'm so busy all the time and it's hard.
Sometimes I'll have something
on in the background
while I'm trying to do more work
and that kind of thing, but
it's not always a stream.
Yeah and I'm also very picky.
I don't stick around in streams
for a long time, actually.
I never really watched
them start to finish.
- Right, right, right.
Yeah so like what's...
(clears throat)
What's the life of a VTuber like?
Like what does your typical day look like
when it comes to like your VTuber work
and everything like that?
- Well, of course, as I've
mentioned before, to many,
many know that I work
three jobs in my existence.
- Which is absolutely crazy
when I found that out.
- Yeah, (laughs) I mean.
- I work one job and I'm like, "Fuck man."
(laughs)
Holy shit, you know.
- I mean yeah, it'd be like that.
I mean, on the daily I'm
swinging my scythe around.
I have the scythe swinging lessons.
They're real important.
And I have to do them, I
can't just stop doing them.
It's it's not something...
Even, it doesn't matter
how successful I am
or how many souls I've taken, et cetera,
or how many rainbows
chat has thrown at me.
That's something that I can't
get out of, ever, for a while.
I do those
and then I come back to
my apartment and I stream
whatever I think is cool.
- How you have the energy
to stream after that is just beyond me.
- Well see, here's the interesting thing
about what you just said is
that I don't have the energy.
(laughs)
- I don't.
- Now that's where the wine comes from.
- Exactly.
- That's why you do so
many drinking streams.
Oh it makes so much sense now.
- So that was a fucking lie.
(laughs)
No because it's insane.
Like it's not just like you,
but like there's so many
hololive members, especially
and like other VTubers who
can just stream for like...
I already have trouble streaming
for like more than two hours.
And I'm extremely way
more relaxed in my streams
than I am with like this show
or like my YouTube videos.
And I still can't maintain like
after two hours, I'm like...
I actually like, can't even
act like I'm relaxed anymore.
Like I actually I have to
just be off camera now.
- I know in a previous
episode that I said,
"Oh man, I hope the cut is fair, but..."
And that makes it sound even
more like the cut isn't fair,
but the hololive people over
there, assured me it was safe.
He was like, "Connor, it was very mean
"what you said, the cut
is good, I assure you.
"And yeah, it's all good."
Just saying, I found
out it's good (laughs).
- So fine.
They don't work two jobs
'cause they're broke.
(laughs)
- It's because I have to.
- It's because they can.
- Well I'll say that, is that good?
Can we leave it...
Ah it's so great, we're good.
(laughs)
- Sorry, I just wanted to say that.
- No, its all good.
- One thing I've always wondered
with like a lot of like
the hololive members,
but it's about like how
you guys see yourselves
because you guys are technically
virtual idols, right?
- I guess so huh.
- Yeah.
But do you see yourself as an idol?
You know, when you like debuted
and get all these, simps
and donations and everything.
Like how do you view yourself
as like a public figure?
- Wow.
To be honest, I'm still
trying to figure it out
'cause it happens about
a month ago, right?
I suppose all that I
can say is I actually...
Before all of this,
when I was just doing underground things
in the underworld rap scene,
I kind of like stuck up my
nose a bit at idols, I suppose.
I had this attitude
of oh, there's this whole industry
built around like worshiping these people
that are supposed to be more than human,
when they're not.
- Can't imagine.
(laughs)
- Sounds like, yeah, pulls 10 on gacha.
- And I really kind of
stuck up my nose like,
"Oh, I'm so much better than them.
"I'm no idol, I'm not an idol rapper,
"I'm an underground rapper,"
and that kind of thing.
But then after actually getting
into the industry and...
Actually, no, it was
before, it was before that.
I guess I will give a
small shout out, I suppose,
to the indie, well, not
necessarily indie VTuber,
but one VTuber that
kind of changed my mind
about idols is...
She's really under the radar, I think.
Her name is Milky Queen
and she's like a rice themed VTuber.
She speaks fluent English,
and Japanese.
And we kind of became friends
and she really changed my mind
about idols because she's
so down to earth and kind,
and an incredible singer and talented.
And I saw the activities
that she was doing,
and I went to her events
where she was doing like...
What is it?
The Gacha Events that are big
competitions that VTubers do
to get like sponsorships
and that kind of stuff.
- VTuber and Gacha?
- Wait, wait, wait, wait.
Gacha Events?
- They're called...
It's called Gacha Ebit.
- Right, what are those about?
(babbles)
(laughs)
- Let's go back to the Gacha.
- I think it's a different meaning though.
It's different than that kind of gotcha.
But you do events like
compete for sponsorships
and there's this whole other culture
that I don't know anything about.
But I saw how hard she was working.
- It's like a tournament
office sponsership.
- Yeah kind of like that but they stream.
They stream and it's like
whoever gets the most stuff
thrown at them
in this application--
- I think it's about someone
being like, "I really need
"that first price raise shatter legend."
- Right yeah, that sponsorship.
- Excuse me I'm a diamond
ranked Gacha player.
I'll have you know.
- I'll have you know I'm whale.
- My part is called a whale.
But no, no...
I'm a challenger here
- I'm not a whale, I'm a
diamond league Gacha Player.
(laughs)
- I'm a professional challenger
here at Gacha Player,
I'll have you know.
- I kind of love that.
Yeah, it was like she competed
against a bunch of other VTubers
and they were competing for like,
to be the image girl of a
restaurant or something.
- So how'd you compete?
- By streaming and you
stream at the same time
as some of these other VTubers
and it's like whoever gets
I think the most stuff thrown at them...
There's an application I probably
shouldn't even talk about
or mention,
but there there's a place
for it, they do that anyway.
- Especially it's just
like a donation war.
- Exactly.
- It's a donation.
- It's a simp tournament, guys.
(laughs)
- Which by the way...
- That's what it is (laughs).
- I will state hololive
has nothing to do with
this by the way we...
This is just something
I know as me Calliope,
the death god, from what I've been--
- Surely that must add more
stress to streaming though.
And streaming is already pretty stressful
adding that kind of...
These boys are fucking dying here.
I'm trying to find...
(laughs)
- I kinda love that though, to be honest.
- That's a new meme on the subreddit.
Holy shit.
- No.
That's super interesting.
- It is.
- I wanna go to those so bad.
- Holy shit.
- Well, that was kind of my
first exposure, to be honest
to the whole VTuber thing.
I didn't really understand
it and I watched her things.
And I guess...
I suppose getting back
to the idol thing, right?
I kind of had these ideas about
what idols were really like,
but I realized watching
her stuff she works so hard
and she's talented and kind and humble
and other idols can be like that too.
Whoa, no way.
No wonder so many people like them.
And then I realized I was
being a jealous little whore
and now it's why...
(laughs)
- So it's no problem.
- So you were all like,
"You drop this queen."
(laughs)
- Yeah, exactly.
So ever since then I've had no problems
or weird feelings like that anymore.
I've just kind of rode
into the whole idol thing
like with a lot of respect
for my fellow idols
and all the hard work that they're doing
and my mind completely changed,
which is something doesn't happen often.
- I mean, you are an idol now, right?
- Right, it would be kind of weird
if I was shitting on myself.
I suppose...
- I'm curious because
obviously as an idol,
there's always a lot of, like
you said, worshiping going on.
Do you, is it...
I mean, do you get a lot of people
obviously trying to worship you
to an extent that's uncomfortable?
Is that something you
ever have to deal with?
- Well, I feel like...
I feel like for their sake,
I try my best not to get uncomfortable
because I know how that is to
really, really admire someone,
but you don't want to
make them uncomfortable.
- Yeah.
- Right?
- We've been there before.
- Yeah.
- Definitely.
- And I feel like
people mostly have like
really good intentions.
I like to believe that most
people have good intentions.
- You can tell when someone
has the bad intentions
coming up to you, right?
- Yes, oh, for sure.
- Yeah, obviously, like you said, as well,
you were a underground rap cop before.
Is it frustrating
when people try to focus
on what you were before?
- Oh, for sure.
Yeah, I get real sick
of that to be honest,
even sometimes when I just...
I stop streaming and I go
down to the underground,
the underground Cypher or whatever,
and I'll go spit some bars.
I still get some assholes
coming up to me being like,
"Hey, hey, so how's the
VTuber thing going on?"
And I'm just kind of like, "Come on, man."
- It's good.
Thank you for asking.
Thank you.
And it's kind of like, I
like what I'm doing now
and I want things to just
kind of stay this way
and have those fond
memories of the past as well
and just kind of live...
I don't mind living in those
two different ways, I suppose.
- Yeah I mean.
- Fine with me.
- It sounds like you like trying
to do a lot of different things and...
Like, you know, doing this VTuber thing
is just another path on like another skill
that you're trying out.
- Right, exactly.
- Are you enjoying it as
much as you thought you would
or did you even think about that
when you wanted to become a
VTuber in the first place?
- Well, to be honest, when I auditioned,
I honestly didn't think
that I was ever going to get in at all.
So I never thought that far, really.
But...
I don't know if I can say
if one way was more fun
than the other.
They're different kinds of fun, right?
So it's kind of like that.
And I don't mind those two existences
being existences.
How do I say?
I'm bad at words.
And in case you couldn't tell,
the Rapper Reaper is bad at words.
But yeah, I don't mind them being parallel
just don't be an asshole is
all I'm gonna say to you.
Just don't be an asshole, you know.
- I like that.
- Be normal.
You can enjoy--
- You can be parallel
don't be an asshole.
- Exactly.
- So you said you like didn't
know much about VTubers
before you became one,
so what made you like want
to audition to become one
in the first place?
- Well, let's see.
I do think...
I mentioned this story
briefly before onstream,
but I had some other Reaper mates
who also were looking
into the hololive thing
and were talking about
it and I just kind of...
I listened in and I was like, "Oh, okay.
"Sounds interesting.
"I'm getting sick of
swinging my scythe around
"all the time."
And what's interesting though, is that...
I kinda didn't say
anything, when I auditioned,
to those friends...
- Oh no!
- I was just kind of, "Oh,
I'll just give it a shot."
'Cause I didn't think
I was going to get in.
I thought that they had
way better chances than me.
And so I was like, "Oh,
okay, I'll just do it.
"I'll just do it for shits and giggles."
Just for fun.
And then about midway through
before we even heard anything,
before things even got
moving, I got real guilty.
So I told my friends.
I said, "Hey, listen like I didn't,
"I went ahead and I
auditioned for the thing
"that you guys did.
"Yes, just so you know.
"I'm not trying to be slimy or anything
"before things start popping off, right,
"just letting you know what's up."
And it was all cool.
- So you betrayed your friends.
- No, no, no.
It's not like that.
- Top 10 anime betrayals.
Right on Trash Taste.
- Its not like that.
- No wonder you have to drink,
to get the sorrows of betraying
your friends away.
- Top 10 anime betrayals.
(laughs)
- Listen.
- So like what was their reaction
when I guess they found out--
- Yeah, oh my God!
They must have been like
fucking mortified or...
- I mean, the good news is
they were very happy for me.
- Yeah, yeah.
- On the surface.
- That's how you know
you have good friends.
(laughs)
- I'm so fucking happy for you.
- So fucking happy for you.
(laughs)
- I think it was genuine though, I think,
but I get what you mean.
- I'm about to go death god
myself.
- For sure.
- I mean, they're your
friends, you gotta...
You must've known that
was a slight bit of like,
"I'm so happy for you,
"I'm so happy for you."
(mumbles)
(laughs)
- I mean, we still talk and
we still cheer for each other.
So I like to hope that things
are still cool with them.
- On your pile of money.
- They're just watching this sweating.
They're like, "Yeah..."
- Oh man.
(laughs)
- Oh my God.
- I imagine you had to buy the
first few rounds of drinks.
- I'm sure that I will.
I'm sure that I will have to,
whenever it is that we
reunite in the underworld.
- So I guess like what is your...
I guess, you've only been doing
this for a month now, right?
And I assume that you're
planning to do this
for the foreseeable future--
- Yes, for a while, yeah.
- Yeah of a while.
Like is there any like immediate goals
you're looking towards as--
- Oh gosh!
- Tell us your five-year plan.
As a death god--
- Where do you see yourself
in five years?
- Where do you see yourself in five years?
- We're like doing a
fucking job interview here.
- Miss eternal death god.
- Well let's see.
Well, think about it this way,
I've lived a long existence
so five years is like to
me what a second is to you.
So it's all good.
For me basically...
There are many things
that I have on my list.
So for example...
I want to release an album,
a full album and then I don't know
if I will ever be able to get a 3D body.
It would be nice.
I can't promise anything
and I don't know anything,
but it'd be nice if I did.
And at that time I'd like to release
some kind of EP for that.
That would be cool.
- Are you listening hololive staff?
- Hi guys.
- She wants a 3D.
Oh yeah because yeah--
I just realized like I don't
think anyone in the EN side
has had their 3D debut yet.
- We've only been...
- Nope, not yet.
- Like we said, they've only
been debuted like a month ago.
- Yeah, I always forget that.
- I'm like yeah Hololive
English has been around
since the beginning.
- I've just become so
comfortable with their simping
that they're just like,
"Yeah, I'm ready to do this for life."
- Its like, "Shit I've been
simping here for only a month.
"What the fuck!"
(laughs)
"It feels like years."
- We're in this for the
long run, everyone, maybe.
- That's gonna be really
interesting though
when that gets debuted.
- I think so for sure.
I have no idea what even to expect,
but then again, I didn't
for this job either.
So Hey, looking forward
to it, if it ever happens.
- Yeah, 'cause I mean like...
It's still a little fucking crazy
that it's just been a month.
What was your opinion of VTubers
like before you auditioned
and everything like that?
- VTubers?
- Yes.
- Or YouTubers? Oh okay.
- Or just like...
Or like online content
and everything like that.
- Okay, well I never thought
it was something I could do
because as I've mentioned before,
I wouldn't say that I'm a shy person
because I can talk well in conversation,
but I'm very much an introvert.
So I don't talk to people
unless they talk to me.
It's that kind of thing.
I don't approach others
and I like being alone
and I get real...
Sometimes I get real sick of folks.
You guys are fine.
(laughs)
I just want to clarify
real quick you guys are...
It just depends.
Mostly like party situations
and that kind of space,
a ton of people, right?
You just kind of people to off
and leave you alone after that.
- I mean, to be fair, I'm like...
I don't mind the occasional
party every now...
But could I go to one every day? No.
- Nah, exactly.
You get kind of tired after a while.
- I know you kinda--
(murmurs)
- And so I also am not...
Ah gosh.
I've gotten used to talking,
but I'm not really...
I'm not a being that really enjoys...
It's not that I don't enjoy it.
I'm bad at talking about myself
and I have a hard time
talking about myself
without getting a little
flustered, I guess.
So for this job, I thought, "Wow."
I feel like you have to have a...
There has to be a certain
level of not just confidence,
but like ability to talk about yourself
and well about yourself, I guess.
So I just don't...
I'm not sure if I knew if
that was for me or not.
I've been very unsure about it.
I really didn't have any
streaming experience at all.
- I mean, I've always said
that YouTube is like...
Like the best YouTubers are
always the most narcissistic.
Like you have to love
yourself quite a bit, I feel
in order to, for you to be
confident enough to be on camera,
to be like, "Look at me
and look how awesome I am."
- Well I would say that it is
a skill that you can learn.
I mean it's--
- Yeah, but I'm talking
about like the most like
naturally talented YouTubers.
- Oh yeah.
- Right.
They can just go and be,
"Hey guys, hit that like and
subscribe button," et cetera.
Like that really kinda outward.
- Like, no one says that
on their daily life,
like anything of that sort.
Like you know (laughs).
You know the feeling you can
learn to do that after years
but there're people who can
just like come immediately
onto the scene
and just look like they'd be doing it
for like five, 10 years.
- Honestly, I've been
doing this for 10 years
and it's still like...
I still die inside a little bit when I--
- When you say like and subscribe.
- When you say like and subscribe--
- Yeah it hurts, doesn't it?
- I hardly ever say
to my own videos.
I'm like, I can't do this for every video.
- Yeah, exactly.
- I wonder then
off of that saying that
like they hate doing that,
is there something that you don't like
about being a VTuber?
- Oh wow.
- Or a streamer?
Like there's gotta be something
that's like, you know, grind
your gears, isn't there?
- Oh, sure, absolutely.
Well, gosh, I mean...
Let's see...
- Sorry, the list--
- Your manager is
sitting over there sweating right now.
- I know right, I see
him over there he's like,
"Ah shit, oh fuck, oh no."
- Please be nice.
- I mean...
I feel like most of the issues that I have
always end up being with
myself, for whatever reason,
like, "I could do this better."
- That's not the answer
we were waiting for.
- I know its not.
- Come on!
- I'm thinking.
- I'm just not perfect enough.
- I know I'm thinking.
- That's like the job
interview answer you give
whenever like--
(laughs)
You know when you're in a job interview
and someone asks you, "What
are your flaws?" I'm like--
- I work too hard.
- I just work too hard.
- I'm just such a hard
worker, I'm a perfectionist.
- That's too much information.
- I work too much.
I never sleep.
Yeah, exactly.
- Well let's see.
If I'm to be honest, let's see.
I mean, obviously sometimes Chat...
They mean well and I love my Chat.
- Listen, there're people
and some people are assholes.
It's okay to say that.
- Exactly.
And you know, people tricking
me into saying things.
I don't like it.
Listen, I understand that you support me,
go fuck yourself.
Please don't please stop.
- Yes! She said it!
- Can you stop it.
- That's some brand though right?
Tell someone to go fuck themselves, right?
- I mean I'm trying so
hard to be entertaining
and for all of us to have fun together.
And you're just trying to shit on my day
and everyone's day.
- It's rude.
- Yeah you tell 'em.
- Its fucking rude.
- You tell 'em.
- You tell 'em, man.
- We want an hour
of you talking shit.
- You dropped this queen.
- It started going off.
Gotta get the angry phase going, right?
This is my sad face.
Looks like I'm in pain.
I'm sorry, excuse me.
Sorry.
Now I'm blushing.
Hang on just a moment.
I have to adjust myself.
Okay, yeah. Fuck you.
(laughs)
I'd raise my nakayubi if I
could, but I can't right now.
- [Joey] Oh, I didn't.
- I'm happy that we've got that moment.
- There's gonna be plenty--
- Hold up
I'm changing my face.
(laughs)
- I'm changing my face.
- Finish changing my face.
- You won't like me when I'm angry.
Hold up, hold up, let me just get angry.
(laughs)
- There's also some other
stuff that pisses me off
in terms of like technical
difficulties and whatnot,
because I was under the impression
that I was doing a pretty decent job.
But (chuckles) you know,
in the beginning my PC specs are fun.
You know, they're still pretty shit.
But eventually they got better stuff.
There's a lot of feedback
about stuff that I can't change
and I know it's my job to take it
and to do what I can
with it and we did that,
but there gets to a point--
- It's been like my old computer.
- Yeah.
- Oh my God.
- Joey, (laughs) can
we tell the story Joey.
- I mean, it was eventually
going to come up anyway.
- So I had ordered a new PC
build, like I bought everything,
I got Joey to buy the exact same one--
- Because I needed an upgrade too.
- And so we ordered
the 380 graphics card which is the new...
I don't know if you're familiar
with any of that stuff.
- Yes, now I am.
Oh believe me chat made sure I know.
- So we ordered it and it got delayed.
So when I was building
Joey's new PC for him,
he didn't know how to build it.
- To preface, Joey has
like the most junk setup
you'd ever expect for
like professional YouTube.
He fucking streams and
edits on one screen.
One screen!
- Oh man.
- How'd you do that?
- Oh dude.
- That's like a monster.
- I tried like--
- The man is just looking
at me like I killed a puppy.
- He's like, "What?"
- Dude.
- I tried working on one screen, I'm like,
"Why am I blind one eye?"
You know what I mean?
That's how I feel when
I have one YouTube--
- He's a professional in
all senses of like this job.
- I've been doing this
for almost eight years now
and I've been doing in one...
- How'd you read the comments?
He's like, "Oh, just
pop it up in my phone."
- Do you have two monitors?
- Alt-Tab is my friend?
- I have four.
- Now Joey, come on.
- Joey.
- So I was building Joey's new PC
and obviously the 380 hadn't arrived yet.
So I said, "Don't worry Joey.
"We'll just take the
old one out of your PC."
- 'Cause I had a 980 in my old one.
- And you know when you
have a new graphics card,
they have like little
rubber pieces in the HDMI
and the display port.
They were still in on Joey's thing.
And I thought, "Oh, did
you put them back in Joey?"
And he was like, "No."
And I'm like, "Did you
ever take these out?"
And he was like, "No,
I never took them out."
So Joey for five years...
Joey for five years
used a 980 graphics card
that was plugged in
powered and never used it.
- He was still using the
Intel CPU graphics card.
(laughs)
- He plugged his one HDMI monitor
into his fucking motherboard.
(laughs)
- Oh my God, dude.
- He's a professional YouTuber streamer.
- So basically--
- I was fucking losing it.
- So basically when we
pulled out this like dusty,
old thing--
- It was so dusty.
- It had never been used.
(babbles)
- It had never been used for five years.
So basically it was the
dustiest brand new 980
that you'll ever see.
- Oh my God.
- I have no idea how
he didn't have problems
with like streaming or editing videos.
- It's pretty nuts.
- That's what you get
for like, just playing...
Just playing anime games.
- Honestly dude like A,
I only play retro games,
and B, I'm a console player.
So like I've never had to
deal with like graphics card
or any of that kind of shit.
But I guess now I do.
- So no, it doesn't
matter how bad you are.
- The manager's fucking losing it.
- Joey...
(laughs)
- He's fucking crying.
- Hololive staff members
start crying on stage.
Joey for five years had a
graphics card that he did not use.
- I never used it.
(laughs)
- And this wasn't like Joey built it,
it was pre-built so he had no excuse.
- But that's the problem, right, was A,
because like every computer
I've used up on like my entire life,
because my dad worked in IT
for like fucking 30 years.
- He--
- Just stop.
- He never taught me any of this shit.
(laughs)
- [Calliope] Oh my God.
- He would just set this shit off for me
because I remember like--
- You like to be my grandma.
You're just like, "Oh how--
- I'm literally one step away
from like, how does email work?
(laughs)
- I get that.
- Yeah so like...
'Cause I never like...
I never PC game, like my entire life.
I've always been console
only, like ever since I was...
And it's only recently I
started PC gaming, right?
And so--
- 'Cause of this guy.
- Yeah, because of like, you
know, all my friends were not.
So, and especially when
streaming came into the image,
because I couldn't stream
in Australia, right?
Like my upload speed get...
- That's what I've heard.
- Yeah.
Do you know what my upload
speed was in Australia?
- Tell me.
- 0.4.
- Come on, man.
That can't be a real.
- 0.4 meg.
- You can't stream on that.
- I couldn't stream dude.
- Oh G.
- I stream fuck like an NES emulator
and it was still wagging.
- What!
- Yeah I couldn't stream.
So of course, because I
had this garbage computer
with this garbage internet,
PC gaming was just completely
out of the options for me.
- Yeah, makes sense.
- And so when I moved here
and I was like, "Oh my God,
"I can actually stream."
- Internet can be fast.
- It's like coming back
to the 21st century.
- It was like, "Oh my God, upload speeds
"that are more than a megabyte.
"Holy shit!"
And then, yeah.
(giggles)
Just like crappy Scott, basically.
I was an absolute clown about it.
And these two will never
let me forget about it.
- Something kind of beautiful about that.
I feel good about myself now.
Thank you for that confidence.
- Were you mainly a PC gamer
or a console gamer before?
- Nah, I've played consoles
ever since I can remember.
- What's your favorite like...
- What's your favorite
console of all time?
- Oh gosh. PlayStation two.
(babbles)
- Good choice.
- I almost feel like white bread as well.
(laughs)
- The best memories that I have--
- What do you mean just a DVD player?
- Yeah, I did. I played
many DVDs on it as well.
- Of course you did.
- Yeah, it was very, very...
What's the word?
I forget English.
You can use it for many things.
Versatile.
- Versatile, there you go.
- The video is sponsored by Mack Weldon.
The new normal uniform
has a lot of us searching
our closets and drawers
for men's essentials that aren't there.
Instead of the usual business,
casual button-ups and jeans,
it's soft knit polos, tees,
joggers, an active shorts.
Whatever men's basics you need,
Mack Weldon has you covered
with unmatched comfort to fit.
The script tells me to show you.
These are my boxers,
that Mack Weldon sent me.
No joke, they're great.
I've worn these many (laughs) times.
This is probably--
- You did wash?
You didn't wash them.
- These are clean.
- Joey. You wanna feel these, Joey?
- Maximum comfort!
- Memes aside they're good.
- Yeah I'm wearing the
Mack Weldon T-shirt.
I wear this all the time to the gym
'cause ooh look, it's so breathable, man.
- [Connor] Yeah there's
so many holes there.
I could fucking breathe out of that.
- I don't see your nipples, basically.
- You might notice
that I'm looking a little
different, this sponsorship,
but that's because I'm covered
head to toe in Mack Weldon.
I've got the beanie,
I've got the face mask
because Mack Weldon gives you
all sorts of different clothes.
- [Connor] They have
men's essential socks,
shirts, hoodies, underwear,
polos, or active shorts.
Mack Weldon, promises,
comfort, and consistent fit.
They have everything you need.
The versatility is insane.
You look great.
Joey, do you feel great?
- I do feel great.
- Of course you do.
From working out, to going out,
going at work or on a date.
Oh wow! Mack Weldon is for everyday life.
- And don't forget about the technology
behind their were as well.
Wide range of customized fabric
that can keep up with you
no matter what your day looks like.
18 hours, silver, AIRKNITx,
dry knit, warm knit.
I don't even know what
half these words mean.
- Just keep telling me knit,
Garnt, I'll buy it, I'm down.
Mack Weldon's quality speaks
for itself, I'll buy anything.
- But there's also the
loyalty program, Weldon blue,
which is totally free.
Level one gets you free shipping for life,
gentlemen.
- Get outta here.
- For life?
- That's entire life for life.
Wow.
- That's a deal.
And once you reach a level
two, by spending $200,
you get 20% off every
order for the next year.
- I just read that in the script
and even I'm shocked at
the value of that deal.
- And we can make a guarantee.
I guarantee--
- The Mack Weldon guarantee, that is.
- That if you don't like
your first pair of underwear,
you can keep them and
they'll still refund you.
No questions asked.
- They're basically giving
underwear out for free.
- We're so excited about this.
That we're just going to
keep interrupting each other.
- Mack Weldon for 20%
off your first order,
visit MackWeldon.com/TrashTastes
and enter promo code trashtaste.
That's MackWeldon.com/TrashTastes.
- MackWeldon.
- Promo code trashtaste
for 20% off.
Mack Weldon, reinventing men's basics.
Mack Weldon, thank you to
Mack Weldon. Mack Weldon.
- I gotta say, my favorite
console though, GameCube.
I don't know what it is--
- Oh for sure.
- GameCube for me. I'm a GameCube boy.
- I'm really sad that like
even though GameCube...
Some of my favorite games of
all time are GameCube games
and yet I never owned a GameCube.
- Like what!
- Yeah.
- Well then how did you enjoy them?
- Because I had a childhood friend
who I used to go to his
house like three times week
and he had...
He was that one friend
who clearly had like a really rich dad.
Or like a dad who like worked
in like the gaming industry,
like the tech industry.
And he just had like all the consoles.
- You knew that someone had a rich dad
when they owned more
than one of the consoles.
- Yeah right.
- You know.
(laughs)
- You can be a GameCube kid and
a PlayStation 2 kid as well?
Like how does that work?
- And almost always, for some reason
that one kid always has like
a fucking like projector
as well, like on the wall.
- Yeah, a screen.
- I'm like, "What do you use this for?"
He's like, "To play games."
It's like, I have like a shitty CRT TV
that (laughs) I play games on.
- I really liked the GameCube.
And I got a super cheap one as a kid
'cause obviously it bombed so hard.
They were basically like giving it away
with like three hundred
tons of free games.
I fucking loved it,
I played the shit out of Sonic Riders.
That was terrible game.
(laughs)
- For me though like my favorite
stole was Super Nintendo,
just cause I'm like a
hardcore, like retro head.
- I really wanna get a Neo Geo.
- Neo Geo?
- But they're so expensive.
They're like 700 bucks to get one
and all the games are like really...
Like getting any metal slot
game is like 300 bucks.
- It honestly would be cheaper
to just get like a cabinet,
like an Arcade Cabinet--
- Honestly, like yeah.
- Metal Slug.
I love Metal Slug.
- That's it Metal Slug.
- It's my favorite like game series ever.
- What are like your favorite games?
- Oh gosh, let me think.
I've got quite a few.
- FIFA?
- Oh yeah, for sure, gotta...
- Football Manager 12?
- Yeah, throwing the ball.
- Madden?
- Yeah for the three pointer.
I love my football.
Now, let's see.
Actually though I really...
I have a wide range of games that I enjoy,
but right off the top of my head,
some of my classic favorites,
I would have to say one
of my favorite games ever
is Bloodborne.
I love souls games.
Because let me tell you
something real quick.
I suck shit at DOOM, I get that,
but get me into any souls
game, we'll have some fun.
- Listen--
- Have you streamed any yet?
- I can't, unfortunately.
But you know, maybe someday.
We're working on it.
Who could say what will
happen in the future?
I really want to play
a Bloodborne with Ina
because she is familiar with
the Cthulhu stuff of course,
as you may know
- I like Bloodborne because
it's the only software game
that I actually could finish.
Like I've never been able
to finish a dark souls game
'cause they're still way too hard.
- Nor have I.
- Have you played Sekiro?
- Oh yeah, for sure.
- Did you like that?
- Yeah I loved it.
- I fucking love that game.
It's so hard though.
- I still haven't
played it though.
- It's so good but it's so fucking hard.
- Yeah, that one gave me
some trouble, honestly.
For me in terms of like, I
guess, skill at the games,
I would probably say Bloodborne is the one
that I can pretty easily do.
After that Dark Souls,
a little more difficult,
but I can get through them.
Sekiro is like the most difficult.
- Yeah I've heard Bloodborne
is like the more difficult one.
- I thought it was the easiest one.
- It depends on what play
style I think you like.
- Yeah because like Dark Souls...
What makes Dark Souls
so like tough for people
is that you really have to be patient.
Like Bloodborne you can
kind of just like run in.
Just like Hack and slash--
- Right and you're rewarded
by going in and being proactive.
- Yeah, exactly.
But with Dark Souls,
if you run in you're immediately dead.
- That's why I like DOOM, man.
You literally are just rewarded
for just being like a...
Just a monkey.
- I I didn't realize that
until I started playing it more
and I was like, "Oh, I see
what kind of game this is."
- And then Sekiro was like the combination
of Bloodborne and Dark Souls, right?
It requires the patience of Dark Souls,
but if you want to and
you're skilled enough,
you can just run it.
- Wait, wait.
- Exactly.
- Now that we're on
this topic, I gotta ask,
do you care about your
stories and your video games
or do you skip all the guidelines?
(laughs)
Are you just a gameplay gal?
- It depends on the story, to be honest.
It takes a lot to get me
invested in the story.
It has to be...
It has to have something
really special, I think,
otherwise I'll skip everything
if I just enjoy the gameplay.
It just, it really depends.
For example, I really liked,
Bloodborne's very subtle lore,
I would say, I enjoyed that aspect of it.
- You're the 1% by the way.
(laughs)
- Yeah, I'm pretty sure, I guess.
But I liked the, the subtle storytelling.
It just depends is I
guess the basic answer
that I would give.
- So the game boots up,
right, first cut scene plays.
You'll always get the first
cut scene of chance or you--
- Yeah I would say so.
- I'll just immediately skip
every single time.
- Oh wow, okay.
- I'm like, "I wanna get in the damn game.
"Stop fucking
"making me watch shit."
- Okay, I see.
- And I'm like, "Oh,
there's an Allo cutscene
"before I can play the
game, fucking brilliant."
- [Joey] Yeah.
- Grab your popcorn.
- I was actually watching
this game--
- I was going to get a PS4
to get Death Stranding.
But when I heard there was
like a movie at the end--
that' like unskippable.
- Oh yeah the last...
The final cutscene
was two hours long
- I was like I'm okay
I don't want that.
- I mean, Death Stranding
sounds like the worst game
you could possibly play
because even the game play
is not really gameplay.
It's just walking.
It's a walking simulator, right?
- That's what I've heard.
That is the word on the street.
I personally haven't played it yet.
- That's the only reason why I like...
I love my story-based
games, don't get me wrong,
like JRPGs, I'm like
fucking all over that shit.
But when I heard that the last
cutscene for Death Stranding
is two hours long--
- Yeah I was like,
"I'm not buying this."
- And you can't skip it.
I'm just like, "Kojima why?
"You should have just made a movie."
Like why did you...
That's the thing, Death
Stranding isn't a game.
It's just a movie with
a game attached to it.
That's basically what I was...
Kojima was like, "I wanna make a movie."
People are like, "No
one's gonna watch that."
Then it's like, "But what
if I put a game in there?"
(laughs)
- But I think that--
- And then he's like, "Oh."
- I think that when you find
the balance, it's perfect.
For example, the game that I
really wanna play on stream,
but I can't right now
is Ghost of Tsushima.
- Oh, such a good game.
- Oh!
- I fucking love that game. It's so good.
I've never been obsessed
with the game in so long.
- Like that is the perfect mix
of story and game gameplay.
- I wish life was as beautiful
as what it is, but how it's
portrayed in Ghost of Tsushima.
- Dude, I still really
wanna go to Tsushima?
- Yeah.
- After playing that game.
Like holy shit.
I don't know like...
- I'm a PC gamer and I like
everything, but console.
I used to be like addicted to
X-Box but then I just like--
- You still don't own
a PlayStation, do you?
- No, which is...
I'll get a PS5.
- It's sad.
- I'll get a PS5 it's fine.
- Will you?
- Probably not, to be
honest, I mean, I like...
I have a Switch that I barely play.
- Right?
- [Calliope] Yeah.
I bought like a lot of games to Switch
that have just been unopened.
So I'm like, "I'm a play
that, I'm a play it one day,
"I'm gonna do it," and I never do
'cause then I'm just like, "Alright,"
boot up League of Legends
again and be depressed
for another hour.
(laughs)
- So to contrast Joey's
Virgin gamer sets up.
What is your setup to
when you stream your games
and stream and be a VTuber I guess.
- Well, basically, so far...
Here's basically how my journey has gone
with streaming games.
So right from the beginning, out the gate,
despite having bought a
quote, unquote gamer laptop.
A so called gamer laptop--
- That thing sends a cringe down my spine.
- Yeah.
That's what they call it,
when you stroll into the store
and you're like,
"I need something kind of high
spec for what I want to do."
You walk in, they're
like, "Let me show you."
And they take you over to--
- Are you a gamer?
- Gamer yeah, exactly.
Well, I needed something
that would suit my needs
for animating, for doing
my animation freelance.
So I, you know, told them what I needed.
And they said, "Well, how
about this gaming laptop?"
And I said, "I kinda like games."
(laughs)
I kinda like games.
- That's how they get you.
Okay, well I'll get
this gaming laptop.
- Just a true gamer girl.
- Yeah and I can play games
on it and I can animate.
So I buy it.
And then I realized, yeah, I
can kind of play games on it
at like a medium quality,
but can I stream them?
Oh fuck no.
Oh, I can not do that.
And I realized very quickly
that that wasn't going to work,
especially for this line of work.
So before that, I was just using,
I guess, what is a game capture device
that I route to my television screen
and then I route it into the laptop
and it's able to capture it perfectly fine
than when I'm playing on my console,
because obviously if I'm using a console,
it's not as much of a
problem on my computer
while I'm trying to stream, et cetera.
But I recently needed to
fix that because of course
playing DOOM on PS4 has
been something else,
I tell you what, with PS4
it's just been something else.
I decided we try and get like
a new PC and I received one.
I was very fortunate.
And so I set it up and then I realized...
I thought to myself, "Okay,
great, I can play PC games."
And then I set it up and I realized,
ah, my apartment is so small.
I actually don't have
any space for the mouse
or the keyboard.
So my mouse set up...
- [Connor] Oh my God!
- My mouse is currently
sitting on top of the...
What is it?
The tower, the rectangle.
The powerful rectangle, that
is, I guess the computer.
- Are you serious?
- Oh my God!
- You're fucking with me.
- Yes, so my mouse is on top
of it.
My mouse is on top of it and
I move it about two inches
and then I have to pick
it up and put it back
and then move it another
two inches to try and get
to where I need to go.
- What?
- The mouse to where I needed
to go across four monitors.
Imagine just a crouched
goblin sitting on the floor
with a chair on the floor,
a desk on the floor,
surrounded by four monitors
with my mouse on top of the tower
that is my computer.
- We need to get you a
new cardboard box I think.
- Yeah for real.
- The cardboard box size you got right now
is not big enough.
- Unfortunately when I try to
put the mouse somewhere else,
but then I realized,
"Oh, my bed is there."
There's no room
for anything in my...
- [Connor] Oh my God.
- Well, the good news is though,
I've already mentioned
this before on stream,
I'm moving.
- Hell yeah.
- So now the new place is much
bigger, new desk, new setup.
I'm finally going to be
able to play PC games.
I'm very excited.
- You can finally
get your game a chair like for a game ago.
- I was about to say like the simps
are probably hearing this being like,
"Don't worry queen we got you."
(laughs)
- We got you.
- You need a new apartment,
we'll get that for you, queen.
- Do you accept card?
(laughs)
- Open super chats?
- Here comes the rainbow,
it's raining down.
- I imagine if you're trying
to find a new apartment
in Japan, you'd hope that
like the realtor was a simp
so that they'd probably
make getting a house
in Japan a little easier
because I don't know.
Have you had difficulty
getting an apartment in Japan?
- I did mention this actually
on a member's only stream recently.
I guess I'll go into it a bit here,
but basically, yeah, it's
been tough as a Reaper,
I would say,
finding an abode for me
because as a Reaper, it's
a little difficult, yeah.
And you can say, I do
this and this and this.
But then it doesn't
really matter, does it?
So yeah, but the good news
is it worked out in the end
and for that, I am fortunate.
- That's the ironic thing, isn't it?
It's like, you can be like,
"Yes, I have a multimillionaire
who makes money."
It's like, okay.
That's cool.
- I would like to buy...
- Do you have a uni degree though?
- Do you have a uni degree,
do you speak Japanese?
- How about this thing that
you have no control over?
Okay well sorry but kindly fuck off.
- So you want to buy this whole building,
but you know, it's all good.
I just wonder if you know how to separate
glass from plastic.
I just, I can't fathom if you didn't know.
- We don't have an English
like seat by the way.
Are you gonna be okay?
Like my apartment is four bedrooms.
I don't need four bedrooms.
I only use two of the bedrooms
because no other
apartment would accept me.
So I end up with a place was four bedrooms
and it looks so excessive.
When like people come to my...
Then they're like, "Why
are two of the rooms
"not being used?"
I'm like, 'I couldn't get anywhere else!"
- We go from, "I don't have
enough space to put my mouse,"
to, "I have four bedrooms rooms,
"and I don't need four bedrooms."
(laughs)
- I have a gigantic
tatami which you can have.
I don't do anything with it.
I sometimes go in it,
it smells really weird.
Tatami, I don't like the smell of tatami.
- 'Cause you don't clean it.
- You don't clean it--
- How do you clean tatami?
- I think you throw water on it, right?
- Yeah, there's like special
like equipment that you can use.
- Wait do you have to clean
it if you don't use it?
- I mean yeah, because--
- You do?
- Yeah.
- Why?
- Because it collects mold.
- Oh my God!
- Oh no.
- I mean tatami's made
out of a plant, alright,
so if you don't clean it regularly--
- Fuck if I know that.
- Then it gets moldy.
- How'd you clean it?
- You gotta get that
dehumidifier man, that's--
- Yeah, there's like...
There's different ways that like...
There's like certain, I
mean, I've never done it.
- It doesn't matter,
'cause I they're charging
me anyway when I leave
to replace it.
So if there's animals living
in there when I leave so be it.
- I remember like the week
that me and Sydney moved
into our apartment,
like she stains the tatami mat
(laughs) within the first few days.
(laughs)
And we didn't realize, cause we had...
I think she'd like, we'd like
spilled some water over it
or something.
- It was Red Bull.
I remember her--
- Was it Red Bull?
- Yeah I remember her being
like paranoid in the group chat
being like, "How do I clean
red bull from the tatami mat?"
(laughs)
Yeah, that is the most, like
I-just-moved-to-Japan post.
(laughs)
- Us like Japan life.
- Because as a foreigner
you just don't know
how to deal with tatami rooms, right?
So I'm like, "Can we
put furniture in here?
"How the fuck can we
put anything in here?"
You know what I mean?
- Have you ever lived in a tatami room?
- I have actually.
- Did you like it?
- Back in the day.
Not really, I mean, it wasn't
quite my choice, was it?
Because I recall back in the day
I kind of didn't get to
choose where I lived.
I was moving to a new city
and they were just kinda
like, "Okay, go here.
"This is your place."
And I waltz in, it was super old.
The walls were actually kind
of crumbling on the inside,
there was a really
ancient tatami, actually.
I already had water damage.
So I went ahead and a water
damaged it a little bit more
by actually...
What I did was
I was trying to figure
out how to dry my clothing
because I had a washer outside
and I washed my clothing there
and it was kind of my first
experience in this kind of room.
And I thought to myself,
"Well, I have to hang these to dry, right?
"Okay, I'll just do it in my house."
So I hung it up and it was dripping.
And so...
(murmurs)
Yeah, so I went ahead and I went to sleep
and I woke up and I thought to
myself, "What is that scent?
(sniffs)
"What is that scent in my home?"
And then I looked over to the side
and I looked at the dark
spot on the tatami mat
and I thought, "Oh, I see."
- Oh that's weird.
(laughs)
- The good news is I just kind of ran away
and that was this.
- It's your problem now.
- One thing I will say though
that not many foreigners get to experience
is sleeping on a futon.
And I will say sleeping on a
futon in a to tatami mat room
is like--
- It's nice.
- It's the best night of sleep I ever get.
- Yeah, it's not bad.
- I don't know
what it is about the feeling
of just sleeping on the floor.
I don't know, it kind of
reminds me of grandma,
like sleeping at grandma's
house or something like that.
- I love, I personally
loved the tatami rooms.
- When Garnt first told
me that he loved it,
I was just like that meme of like,
"Is this some peasant joke,
"I'm too rich to understand?"
Is that the meme?
- Yeah, "Is this some peasant joke
"I'm too rich to understand?"
- 'Cause I have an old tatami room.
Like why would I
voluntarily sleep on that?
I have a bedroom bed.
- I don't know, man, like, cause like...
- I like it now.
- Yeah.
- 'Cause when we get a real
count we're forced to stay.
- Like you know, my grandma's
house was nothing but tatami,
'cause it was in the middle
of blood fuck nowhere
in like the Japanese countryside.
And sleep like just lying down on that
in like on a summer day
is like the best fucking
nap you'll ever take.
- Feel like it did wonders for my back.
- Oh yeah.
- Yes.
It is good for your back
- It straightens it out.
- It's strange to think about that.
Sleeping on the floor is like more like...
It feels more healthy
for your back and stuff
than sleeping on a bed elevated.
- Yeah, it is weird, right?
It's kind of an oxymoronic almost.
- Yeah.
- That like somehow the most
uncomfortable sleeping...
- That's how humans have been sleeping
for like most of...
- Alright Garnt, fucking nerd.
- We're going back to
the Neanderthal phase
sleeping on the ground.
- So were you an anime
fan or anything as well?
- Well, I used to watch
anime way back in the day.
I would have to say,
I've seen a lot from...
Let's see.
Maybe, like 2010s, I would say.
But the most recent anime
that I've really enjoyed
is I think I really liked Dr. Stone,
I've mentioned Dr. Stone.
I really liked Made in Abyss.
So those were the two
that I was really into.
- We know that we know the guy
who did the soundtrack to Made in Abyss.
- Really you know?
- Yeah.
- What, I love--
- Shout out...
- Shout out to Kevin.
- Heh!
Wait. I love the soundtrack too.
(laughs)
- He's just this really Aussie bloke.
- Yeah.
You won't be amazed if you
ever meet him in real life.
- Oh yeah?
- He's just a normal Australian dude.
- He's just the most
normal Australian dude.
He was just like, yeah,
I did it Made in Abyss.
- We'll look at drunk
with him. It'll be fine.
- Yeah.
- Oh my God.
That's awesome.
- Dr. Stone, yeah I mean like--
- I kind of thought that
Dr. Stone anime was mid.
There I said it.
Thought it was mediocre.
- Oh that's okay. I can
totally understand that.
I don't really know why I enjoyed it.
I think my method of thought at that time
was, "I haven't watched
anime in a long time.
"Let's just watch something.
"This guy has a head that
looks like a piece of celery.
"Let's just go into it."
And I checked it out and I
really liked the main character.
He made me laugh a lot.
He has like a personality
that I enjoy and yeah.
I mean, I think the characters are fine,
but I don't know what it was.
I think just...
It was a nice comfy show
that I could sit back and not really care
too much about.
- I agree with that, yeah.
- It was definitely comfy.
- I did because everyone was hyping it up
it's like the next big show.
- It's really weird
right 'cause I think...
I think the thing I didn't like about it
was the Shonen side.
The fact that it was like a
typical Shonen Jump anime.
And what I didn't like
was when they had like
these arbitrary battles
and stuff like that.
Like I saw the tournament talk
and it was the first time I was like,
"Why is there a tournament?
"Please get rid of the tournament."
- It's true. That was so bad.
It was like, "Just get back
to the science, I liked that."
- Boo! Get back to the science.
We want the science.
Whenever they were just
inventing stuff like that scene
where they invent the light
bulb, fucking brilliant scene.
- Yeah. That was awesome,
I love that kind of stuff.
- But like when they're
fighting, I'm like,
"Get this shit outta me."
- I think it's what
they might've been like,
at least in Japan,
there might've been
like a prior hype to it
because it was written by the
same guy who did Eyeshield 21?
- Right.
- People were like, "Oh shit!
"This is the guy who wrote Eyeshield 21.
"So it must be just as
good as Eyeshield 21."
And then you watch it and yore like...
- But you also mentioned 2010's anime.
Do you have like a few
favorites you could list off?
- I think I remember
from your debut stream,
you said you really
liked Madoka Magicaright?
- Yes
- Really?
- [Connor] Oh wow.
- A hundred percent big fan.
- Oh, can we call Madoka
Magica a classic now?
(chatters)
- 2011 I think, something like that.
- So far not trash taste.
What else is on your list, I wonder.
- My number one favorite
show of all times is...
It has to be Gurren Lagann.
- Oh wow.
- Yes.
- Good taste.
- That is a classic.
- It was one of my first actually anime
that I really watched and loved.
- Was that like the anime that
you'd say got you into anime?
- Yes, I would say.
Well, because I had
watched a couple before
that my friends in Rieber
school had recommended to me.
For example, like I watched,
of course Inuyasha was just on TV.
So I watched that and then
Fullmetal Alchemist as well.
I watched that and I enjoyed,
but I still thought that anime...
I was like, "Okay, anime is kind of cool."
I drew it a little bit,
but I didn't really get into it
until I watched Gurren Lagann.
And I was like,
"This made me feel something
that I didn't feel before.
"That's crazy, I love it.
"And maybe animate is like this.
"Cool, awesome, I'll keep watching it."
And still to this day
though I haven't found.
- But unfortunately
we wouldn't see anything like
that for a very long time.
- Exactly
- Yeah. I just checked.
Madoka Magica is 2011. So
I'd say almost 10 years.
Almost 10 years at this
point, which is fucking--
- Fuck!
- Like I just remember well Magical girls
were like before Madoka Magica.
Now like every Magical girl I see
is like--
- Is an edgelord.
- Is like an edgelord.
Is like an edgelord Fest show.
- Yeah, exactly.
- Remember when people were like,
"Damn, Revolutionary
Girl Utena is so edgy."
(laughs)
Then it's like, "Oh shit, nevermind,
"Madoka Magica has like
people actually dying."
- Yeah exactly.
- Like how deep were you into it?
Like, did you watch like
the movies and stuff?
- I haven't seen those yet, actually.
I remember I was...
All that I remember exactly
'cause it was a while ago
I was on the internet while it aired
and I experienced that whole thing
I guess is what I can say about that.
- 'Cause it was pretty
like fucking inescapable.
- Yeah.
- Like everyone was doing--
- I don't think I was watching
anime when it came out.
- Really?
- I hadn't got into anime at that point,
so I never experienced that.
- So you never like experienced
like the golden age, right?
Like the mid two thousands and...
- I guess I didn't.
- What is your golden age Connor?
- What do you mean?
(laughs)
I got into it like 2013, I think.
and that's when I really
like watched the fuck up.
That was like when every single day
it was like 12 episodes.
Oh that's...
- Connor I miss those days so much.
- Would you have been into
anime like that as well?
- Oh yeah, for sure.
- Yeah, you would just watch
any shitty 12 episode anime
you could find.
And you're like, "Oh, so it's Stripe?"
So I don't know what it is--
- I was like, "Oh the
summer season has what?
"27 new series?
"Yeah, I got time."
- No problem.
- I got time.
- And now I'm like, "A 20 minute episode?
"Get this shit out of my face."
- I feel like that's how you can tell
who like a new anime fan is
when they can actually watch anything.
I'm like, "What's wrong with you?
"What the fuck?"
- I dunno, I find it so weird,
because it's my mentality
with watching content
has like changed so much where...
Do you know what I mean
where sometimes a 20 minutes anime episode
just seems like such hard work?
And then I see like a
two hour YouTube video
or like a fucking three hour VTuber stream
and I'm like, "I got time."
- It'll be like 20 minutes
of like super, highly produced
million dollar budget,
and then on YouTube would
be like two hours speed run
of Mario's Nipple%.
Which one do you choose?
Dude, Mario Nipple%.
(laughs)
Mario every time man, like, I mean.
- What was really interesting actually,
is that back in the day,
I used to be able to
watch a lot more anime
because I've always been very busy.
I've always been a very, very busy being.
Except back in the day,
I didn't have a problem watching dubs
because I could do my
work and I could listen,
but things have changed.
- So are you just like
a no dub person now or?
- It's not a hard, no on all dubs.
It's not a hard, no, but.
- Do you have a dub that you like?
- Baccano!
- Yes!
(claps)
Good taste.
- I feel like
that's a classic.
- Fuck you Joey.
- Hey!
(laughs)
I never said the Baccano! dub was bad.
There's so many...
There's so many
motherfuckers on the Reddit
who are like, "Well Joey thinks
the Baccano! dub was bad."
I'm like, "No motherfucker,
"I never said that."
- It's just better
than the sub.
- I just think the sub is also a good.
- Yeah and that's fair as well.
- Thank you.
You're my favorite guest so far.
(laughs)
- Jesus Christ.
- Sorry, go ahead.
- You were talking about Dublin and stuff.
- I don't want to ever
be one of those people
that's like, (sneers) "No dubs."
Because that really kind of just puts
a damper on all the hard work.
- Yeah and Joey's got that on lock down.
(mumbles)
(laughs)
- Joey's like, "As a
professional Japanese person."
- As a professional Japanese voice actor.
- Lemme just pull out my resume.
I don't need to watch that.
I'm sorry for interrupting you.
- No, you're fine, that's okay.
The thing is at the end of the day,
there's also the fact
that just because you
work hard on something
doesn't mean that it's good.
(laughs)
It's harsh.
That's what I say to myself.
I always say because that's
what I say to myself every day.
Just because you work hard on something
doesn't mean that it's gonna be good
and it doesn't mean that
it's gonna be high quality.
- Every dub voice actor
is just like pointing out
the other one, like...
- She sure is a death god.
She just slayed the entire
fucking dubbing industry.
- I'm not even a voice actor.
Please don't come after me, please.
This is about anything.
Not just voice acting,
it's about anything that anyone does.
Listen, please.
- Then the Reaper was just
like, "If you suck, you suck."
(laughs)
- I dunno what to tell you.
- I say it to you because
I say it to me, okay.
- I think more people need to hear that.
- Yeah advice from Cali.
How about you just don't suck?
- Just get good.
(laughs)
- I mean.
- Oh my God.
- Do be like that.
- Okay I gotta ask, 'cause
you do a lot of things
do you produce your own music as well?
- So I've gotten into music production
and I've made some of my
own tracks in the past,
but for this I really want
to put emphasis on quality.
And I don't think that I'm
in terms of producing music
at the level of quality that I want to be
to match my rap vocals.
So of course I reached out
to a producer, a long time...
Somebody whose music I've
loved for a long time.
His name is Ks, Kokoro Beats.
And he does like doujin music.
And also he's like a DJ
and just fantastic.
- Doujin music?
- Yeah, like Touhou, doujin music--
- Like the porg?
- His group.
Yeah so listen.
(laughs)
No, it's a little different.
Like doujin music--
- Doujin doesn't just mean porg.
- Yeah you're tricking me.
- Right it's like--
No.
- Wait, so he makes music for hentai?
- No.
- It's like.
- I'm so confused.
- So basically, so he...
He runs a Touhou dougin
music circle called TamaOnSen
and they do hip hop remixes
of Touhou music pretty much.
- Okay. Just to...
Just to clarify, doujin
in the traditional sense
just means fan made.
- You probably need to explain
what Touhou is as well.
- It's a game
- Touhou is the...
Fuck what is it?
Either.
- A bullet hell game.
- Yeah, I know Touhou.
I like bullet hell games obviously.
No cutscenes.
- Yeah.
- We don't need to explain what Touhou is.
- So like the term doujinshi
just means fan made porn.
- Damn, they really like
adopted that word though.
- Yeah.
- I didn't know there was another meaning
I thought it just meant porn.
- So anything that's doujin
just means it's fan made.
Like it's not actually
official to the franchise.
- t thought it was just
the Japanese word for rule 34.
- I mean, that's what
it is like in the West .
- I mean like going on a bit of a tangent,
but I found it...
Well get back.
- No worries. No don't worry at all.
- I'll make a mental note,
but like I find it
super interesting though
when I first moved to Japan,
when we were having a conversation
with a bunch of Japanese people
and we like trying and...
They have like no word for
hentai, you know what I mean?
And that was super surprising for me
where like what do Japanese
people call hentai?
Because when you want to
refer to like animated porn,
they don't have
like specific words for that.
- How often do you do this
in conversation?
(laughs)
- You were there
in the conversation.
- Was I ?
- You were just like mentally drift out.
- When was this?
When did this happen?
- It was like outside.
It was like one of the Big WOCA Parties.
- I think I do remember
something like this
and I was just like standing
there, like, what is happening.
- So Calli, do you want you watch Hentai?
(laughs)
- What a great question.
No, I don't know what that is.
- Thank God.
I saved your reputation.
- Yeah I just saw
the manager wipe a sweat off his for head.
(laughs)
- There's no need to.
I don't know what they're talking about.
- Getting back to your music,
you were talking about...
Shit, I can't remember what you
were talking (laughs) about.
- We were talking about music my producer.
- Producing your own--
- Producing your own music,
that's what we were getting at.
- Yeah so basically, so I found,
or I rather asked for some help
from one of my favorite producers
who I mentioned is in the
Touhou doujin music circle.
And I wanted to pick someone
whose music that I really, really enjoyed.
So we just started working together
and he's been really helpful
because at the same time,
I'm also trying to learn how to mix.
And back in the day,
when I was doing my own independent stuff,
I got decent at it.
Like, okay, but there's
always this feeling of like,
"Ah, this could be better
and if I do it myself,
"it's not going to be the level
that I know that it can be."
So we'd work on it together.
And I would mix the initial file,
send it over to him and
then he would fix it up
and like, you know, tell me what he did
and like that kind of thing
and kind of a collaborative effort.
So I can kind of learn a
bit, see what he changed,
et cetera, and get better,
but also put out a
quality product, I guess.
- Yeah, 'cause I mean, you've done...
You've said you're producing
your own music as well.
And you've done animation
you mentioned earlier,
like is all this self-taught
or do you have any background in it?
- So when I went to Reaper school,
I did do a little focus
on drawing specifically.
I went and I studied comics,
actually comic writing.
Yes.
And a little bit of animation as well.
But that was, that was
mainly what I wanted to do
aside from reaping, of course.
But yeah, I would say that was my focus,
but then of course, things
changed dramatically
when I realized I wanted to do music
and it was pretty, pretty
late in the game, I would say,
to be honest, I had finished
my schooling and whatnot,
but when I realized what
I really wanted to do,
and I was like, "Oh,
shit, what have I done?"
What have I done? I've existed this long.
And I'm now realizing that
I want to do something else.
And then I started doing the
music thing and realized,
"Oh, I'm better at music than
I am at drawing and reaping."
- Literally everyone who goes to uni.
- I feel literally our entire lives.
- I feel like you go to
university to figure out
what you hundred percent don't wanna do,
which is normally the subject
that you're made to do.
- It's normally the case
where if you're forced to study something
for three, four, five years,
you normally have a good
incline by the end of it,
whether you want to do it or not.
And a lot of the times
when you were like forced to
pick something, when you're 18,
you're like,
"Maybe I'll be good doing this."
Most of the time, you're
gonna get that choice wrong.
- Of course.
- Of course, yeah.
'Cause I don't know a single person
who like actually graduated
from like a degree of any kind
and actually went into that
field immediately afterwards.
Like I feel that's pretty rare.
I mean, of course it's
not zero, definitely.
But like I know a lot of people
who just went into
completely different jobs.
Is there anything else
you'd want to try in the future perhaps,
or new skillsets you want to do
because you seem to be
up to doing anything.
- See, and that's kind of a bit
of a double-edged sword, isn't it?
Because I want to do everything,
but then I start spreading
myself a bit thin, I would say.
There are so many things I wanna do.
Well, it's like, you want
to focus on one skill
and then you're like,
"Maybe doing this would be fun.
"Maybe doing that would be fun."
- Yeah.
- Right, exactly.
- That's how it is. You know?
- So like has being a VTuber
affected like your schedule,
when you're off camera or anything like.
- Oh for sure.
I only sleep for about four
hours a night actually.
- Yeah fuck that.
(laughs)
I need at least like a
seven or an eight hours.
Otherwise I just cannot
function the next day.
I just love sleep too much.
- I understand.
- And I guess, because you're a VTuber,
you don't have to deal
with people being like,
"You look tired, you look tired."
- Exactly isn't that wonderful.
- Are you not eating enough?
Like people just ask me questions like
"Connor you always look tired.
"You look angry Connor."
No I just always fucking look angry.
I always look like this.
- Shocks on you, I am angry, all the time.
- You're right.
- Being on Trash Taste has
made me super self-conscious
about the tiniest things I do.
Like the other day I had like this thread
that was just me drinking, like
weirdly, like taking a sip.
And I'm just like, "What the..."
Do I take sips weirdly?
(laughs)
Is that a thing?
Am I a weird drinker?
(laughs)
- He's laughing because we saw.
We saw earlier on the train here, right?
That like do you know
what the most liked post
on our subreddit is?
It's the video of Garnt
from like the Sydney
episode drinking a corona
and then laughing to himself.
(laughs)
- Because like, at least...
Like, you know, in the case
with like Garnt for instance,
Like you almost never made
like an IRL appearance
in your videos.
You've almost always
exclusively just been--.
- You could have been a Vtuber Garnt
why'd you fucking spoil
it and show your face
for fuck's sake.
- Maybe I will, one day.
- Maybe I am.
- Maybe he is and you don't know.
Anyone around you could be a VTuber
and you'd have no fucking clue.
- Exactly.
- Yeah legit.
Like, I'm sure there's
like a number of people
who like know you in real life,
but probably have no idea
that you're a VTuber, right?
- Well sure, you know,
demons see me on the street
all the time and they're like...
If they hear a familiar
voice, well, fuck 'em ,
I'm not gonna know I'm gonna keep walking
in the other direction.
- I was having this conversation earlier
with, I can't remember who,
but it was, it was like,
imagine if they perfect like
voice synthesizes, right.
- Actually, if you've seen
a derby's one, it's scary.
It's actually scarily good.
- Is it?
- Yeah.
They only need like a small sample
and they can like mimic
your voice, like perfect.
But they haven't released it
'cause I think they're scared to.
- Yeah, 'cause I think once
they perfect voice synthesizers
and make that like
easily like mass, like...
What's the word I'm looking--
- Mass-produced?
- Mass-produced and easily downloadable.
Then it's fucking over 'cause--
- The amount of identity theft--
- 'Cause then everyone could
be a cute anime girl, right?
- I've gotta show you
this clip. It's so scary.
They have like one person
like have her say a sentence,
and then they're able to
like, make them say whatever,
like perfectly it's so creepy.
- The future is here.
- I mean.
- What like...
- My job's gonna be gone.
- You can't even really trust anything
that you hear anymore after that too.
- Like deep fakes man.
Like I'm, I'm glad deep
fakes are being used
for like fucking memes right now or like
♪ dummy dummy ♪
- Like singing Baka Mitai or whatever.
'Cause I remember first
seeing how realistic it is
and I'm like, this is, this is dangerous
in the wrong hands.
- My favorite one
is the KSI,
the Ainsley Harriott one.
(laughs)
- Have you seen that? Oh my God!
I gotta show you guys off
screen, it's so funny.
- [Joey] It was a KSI doing the...
- [Connor] Ainsley Harriott cooking.
- [Joey] Oh yeah
- [Garnt] Oh yes.
I have seen that, yeah.
- [Connor] It's so good.
(laughs)
- Yeah, because there's also like that...
there's also that like
Japanese, like tech group
that made that, like that
the virtual like model.
Have you seen that one?
- No.
- It's like, it's really being...
I forgot what the name of it was.
It was like saya or
like sayu or something.
- You're just like bored about
your employment over here.
- Yeah.
- Basically, it's this like
hyper realistic 3D model
of this Japanese girl.
- That's creepy, fuck it.
- And it legit, like on first glance,
it legitimately looks
like just a regular girl
because they also made her manage to move
and like smile and emote
like a real person.
And it's just...
- Mad Japan man.
They just got the ways to
bring this to the next level.
- You get that
and then you put a fucking
Adobe voice synthesizer
on top of that
and you basically just have
like a legit virtual person.
- No wonder no one's having
babies in this country.
(laughs)
- Scary.
- Why have sex when I
can just program a baby.
(laughs)
- Oh my God.
- That's nuts.
- Yeah. Which speaking about that, like,
do you have any content creators
outside of other virtual
YouTubers or like, you know...
Let's say 3D content.
- Do you watch any 3D YouTubers?
- That you maybe one day wanna
collaborate in the future?
- Gosh, I do.
There's...
- Go on you've had enough simps
it's time to simp yourself.
- Yeah.
- Who do you simp for?
- I'm so embarrassed because
there's really only one.
But I feel like if I say,
I don't know if we'd
ever do a good collabo
if he'd even want to,
because it's a part of his personality
that I like a lot is that I don't know.
I feel like it would be odd,
but I've just been a huge fan.
I'm a huge fan of Kritikal.
- Oh yeah!
(claps )
- Do you know Kritikal?
I mean the other day I let slip.
I accidentally, we were...
I was playing Minecraft with
Gouda and the other girls
and Gouda was leading me into battle
and I accidentally let
out like a quote from him.
We were trying to taunt the
enemy and girl was like,
"Okay, well, if we taunt them
and we break down the bridge?
"Then maybe that's how we get them."
And I said, "Hey pussy boys."
(laughs)
I was like, "Oh fuck,"
immediately after I was like...
- This is gonna be clipping,
he's probably gonna see us.
So Kritikal just saying.
- Kritikal.
- I mean he's collaborated
with Projekt Melody before.
So I don't think--
- It's true.
(mumbles)
- He'll totally do that.
- I mean he's like very clearly a WIP.
I remember after we talked about Jojo,
he DMS me and be like, "Yo, I'm ready
"to come on boy, I'm ready to come on."
(laughs)
- Speaking of Jojo, do you
like jojos I have to ask?
- I've never seen it, I'm sorry.
It's on my list.
- It was nice having you then.
You were a great guest...
- Connor was just like,
"You're my favorite guest."
(laughs)
- And now he's like--
- Just kidding, get off.
- Yeah she was the most
awful guest
- You're in the top five
guests so far that's for sure.
(laughs)
- Listen, I'm going to do,
although I will say I actually,
I did watch a lot of your
videos with Jojo scenes
and yeah...
- Oh thank you I'm honored.
Oh my God.
- Yeah, it kinda made me want
to watch the show actually.
- Wow.
- Yeah.
- Well do it.
- I will.
I will, it's a promise.
I'll do it I promise once I get...
- This is just like...
Trash Taste is just
casually just like secretly
it's just like a cult to get people to.
(mumbles)
(laughs)
(sighs)
- Everybody's personality is just like,
"So Jojo, have you seen?"
- Everything goes back to Jojo.
- Yeah, exactly.
- We should get you to
do some voice acting.
We should get you to...
- That would be a fun video I think.
- Should we get you a dub
over some anime scenes?
- I can give it my best shot.
- Perfect, damn. free content for me.
(laughs)
That's my idea.
No one take it.
- Oh no because I've actually
wanted to like collaborate
with you on like the
rapping side of things.
- Woo yeah sure.
- 'Cause like, I definitely
wanna like get more into that.
Cause now that I'm yeah...
Cause I'll be doing a
lot of stuff with my--
- This is how YouTubers simp by the way.
- Yeah.
- Oh cool really?
- Simps are
collaborating together
- Nice. Yeah, that sounds about right.
I'm down anytime.
But unfortunately I have to say,
I'm no good at freestyling.
- I mean, oh no, I can't
freestyle to saved my life.
- I'm feeling pretty good
- Oh yeah?
- Because legit, like when I like...
When I saw your tweet
about how your debut song
hit like 3 million views,
I think it was or 4 million views,
but just some ridiculous amount of views.
And I was just like, "I'm a try.
(laughs)
"Lemme try and get her attention."
So I just replied being
like, "Hey, we should spit
"on side together."
Never thought I would get a reply.
And then you were like,
"Hey yeah, I'm down."
Everyone was like, clap, clap.
- Oh my gosh.
- It's like immediately
when you see two YouTubers
like talk on Twitter.
They think like, oh yeah,
there's gonna be a collapse
two days later.
Like that's how it was.
- I guess so huh. Wow.
- It's just so funny
where we could have like the
most minimal interaction,
like you could not even talk to them.
You could see like some just
see like, like that tweet
or something would be like that.
And people would be like, "Yo, yo,
"they're totally boning behind."
(laughs)
- They're definitely gonna
collab, this is a sign.
- I feel like the lab coming.
- Oh yeah, for sure.
- It's like, wow.
Like can I just not casually
interact with someone
on the line without having
it be related to business,
all of a sudden.
- Have you had any awkward moments
where you've maybe like liked
a tweet or followed someone?
And then the viewers have
been like, 'Oh my God, why?"
- Oh for sure I mean.
Yeah I see people's messages
or rather their conversations
all the time where they're
talking about the order
in which I followed people.
I think actually there was a...
(laughs)
There was some discussion
over the order in which I followed
the other hololive girls.
They took note of that.
- Well they thought there was
like drama because of that?
Not really drama, but just
people assuming things,
I suppose drawing their
own conclusions. Right.
- What!
- Like creating favoritism, right?
- Yeah exactly.
That kind of thing.
- What the fuck.
- Could you imagine if that
happened to light just us
like being like, "Wow, Joey
followed Connor before Garnt,
"that must mean that Connor
and Joey are like this
and there's something
between Joey and Garnt."
- The amount of conclusions
that I've jumped to
when it comes to our
relationships with other people
was like crazy sometimes over
like the smallest details.
- It's the whole mentality of like,
I know your life better
than you know your life.
It's like, all right, dude,
you can say all you want.
- I mean there's people fucking diagnosing
I was with a new mental health
disorder every episode--
(laughs)
- I feel like it's people
are grasping at straws
because it's all that they have.
They don't actually know any one of us.
So they take what they have
and then they write these stories
because it's all that
they have to go off of
like detectives.
But as we all know, it doesn't really...
- I'm sorry I sip my water
really weird chat, not chat.
(laughs)
I went into Twit about that.
- Porg in the chat.
(laughs)
Can I get a feel as bad, man?
- So I presume you have lots of like...
Maybe is there fanfictions
about you already, I assume so.
- Oh for sure
but I actually am not really
one for reading fan fiction.
- Good. I like that.
I don't do that either. I hate that.
- Why not?
- We've already discussed this, Joey.
It's boring as fuck and
I don't care for it.
Alright.
That's all I need to say.
- Because it's reading?
- Yes.
(laughs)
Because it's boring
- Because he doesn't
like turning book words
into brain words.
- Yeah true.
- Alright, whatever.
I'm a monkey okay.
- What's the thing that Nakey
Jakey recently said again,
goopy, goblin, gamer, brain.
(laughs)
- Okay.
- That's what you have.
- I have that. Okay.
- Yeah, 'cause I'm wondering like,
do viewers also like assume
like your relationship
with other hololive members
or anything like that?
- Oh, for sure.
Yeah. People. Yeah.
That happens a lot.
- Is most of it false or?
- I mean--
or do you like kinda play to that as well?
- I mean it depends.
I feel like a lot of
people see my relationships
with some of the other members
and yeah they draw their own conclusions
and I'm friends with all of them.
I want to make that very clear,
but there's a certain point
that I want to leave up to you.
To your imagination.
Have fun.
That's the most important
part of all of this right
in this business have fun.
- All the fanfic writers
are like, "Alright."
(laughs)
- Do as you please.
- Did you just ask people to write fanfic?
(laughs)
- No, I did not, no.
No, trash taste fanfics, no.
(laughs)
- I won't read it.
- So do you get to hang out
with any other of the members
like off stream as well?
- Yeah Kiara. Yeah, we hang
out sometimes for sure.
Yeah and I hope--
- Yeah because you guys
are kinda like all over the place right?
- Yeah, definitely.
But occasionally I'm...
Let's just say Kiata lives in a place
that is accessible to
me from the underworld.
So it's easy to hang.
We went to dinner the other
day and it was fun, yeah.
- Do you guys like ever talk
about like the VTuber
side of things together?
Or is it just like completely
just no VTuber talk aloud?
- Well, we talk a bit
about business and I mean,
I feel like there's
always something going on
in the VTuber scenes.
There's always plenty to
talk about on that end,
but of course,
we also just talk about what's going on
for both of us as well.
- Sounds like a funny mental image
of like two of you virtual YouTubers
in the corner at Danny's
just fucking off the avatars.
- Yeah.
Just shooting the shoot yeah.
(mumbles)
Let's discuss this...
- Let's discuss business.
(laughs)
- So you're a 2D anime girl,
I'm a 2D anime girl too.
- Hey we should collab.
(laughs)
- Is there anyone on the
Japanese side of things
that you would like to meet in the future?
- Oh, for sure.
I mean, it's just the, yeah...
You know, there's this...
The thing about me that I've said before
is that I am bad at approaching.
I'm bad at making the first move
because I never went to impose, you see.
I'm very much in my own lane
and kind of doing my own stuff.
And I don't wanna get in anybody's way.
I also I'm always concerned about,
does this person really actually like me
and if they don't and I contact them,
well, then I have to deal with
that whole weird situation.
And then realizing they don't like me.
It's just better that I don't know.
I just rather not know that
you fucking hate me man.
- Spoken like a true YouTuber.
(laughs)
- Diaz, like, "Oh, you approaching me?"
Cali's like, "No, I'm
not approaching you."
- No I'm not.
(laughs)
- So I'm like which hololive
Japan members have you...
Have you met any of them?
- No, I haven't.
They're all rather mysterious to me still.
- [Joey] Right.
- Maybe, maybe some someday in the future.
It just depends on the
collaboration situation.
And I know enough Japanese
to be able to communicate,
but there will definitely be bumps
and they may be hilarious
and they may be sad.
I'm just not sure yet I'm
still testing the waters.
- Because from what I've seen
from like different clips
involves from the
Japanese hololive members,
is that almost all of them
are like really, really interested
in the EN side of things.
- I was wondering how much
like cultural cross-pollination
there is like what--
- What the fuck was that,
Garnt. That was a word?
(laughs)
- Like that was a power word right there.
- Fuck it.
- Cultural cross- pollination.
- I literally just said it.
That's probably not even a word.
- Its like he has a
dictionary under the table,
- He just coined when you turn around.
- Is that a term? I don't know.
- It is now.
- Cultural cross-pollination.
Do you have like a lot of Japanese fans?.
What I want to know
is, do like English V--
(laughs)
What's so funny about it?
- We didn't expect that.
- That was the most business
set of words I'd ever heard,
in my life.
Go ahead, sorry.
- So what was I saying? Oh yeah.
Do you get like a little
Japanese fans where English clips
are like translated to Japanese
in it or anything like that?
- Oh yeah.
Sometimes I'll finish streaming
and three hours later,
I'll see a clip pop up of
the stream that I just did
with Japanese subtitles over
it and I'm like, "Oh, okay."
- That is so fucking deadly.
- They have a speed. Yeah.
- It's pretty crazy but
hey, I'm very thankful.
- That cross...
(laughs)
- That's a strong cultural
cross-pollination right there.
- Sorry guys.
- I feel like the real unsung heroes
of the VTuber worlds are
like the translators.
Like, I don't know how many
hours they put into translating,
but I remember like if it
wasn't for like the translators,
I don't think hololive would
be able to grow as much
as it has.
- And all of them like
do it for free as well.
Like they're not hired to do this shit,
they just like...
I just simp this person so hard
that I want the rest of like
my language speaking community
to know about them.
- Yeah. That's definitely true.
I mean, I used to be the same way
in like the music community,
like the Japanese music community.
I would translate songs
just because I wanted the other people
in my fringe community doing.
- Yeah.
- It's like a new like...
That one super obscure Japanese
game never got a release
in the West.
It's like someone
translates the whole thing
and it's like a visual novel.
Like why?
- All the fam translated visual novels.
I'm like, there is like
900 pages of dialogue
that you just translate it for free.
- But you love it so much,
you want to share it with others, right?
You want them to feel that same happiness.
I think that's really cool.
- Shout out to the translators
you guys the real deal.
- Thank you
for the cultural cross-pollination.
- Yeah, that word, whatever it is.
(laughs)
- We're never gonna get over that.
- So like what made you
want to move to Japan
in the first place?
Was it your love for
anime or games or music?
- Well, as I've mentioned before,
the only reason that I'm
here with you guys right now
is because I actually
live in the underworld.
The other side of Japan.
- Australia.
(laughs)
- I'm also from the under world.
- You mean the down under world.
- That's right.
- The down under world.
(laughs)
- I'm sorry that was a
terrible fucking thing.
- No.
- Now we have to getting an Australian.
- Yeah.
- Yeah, it's okay.
I live on, I live on the
flip side, basically.
I live on the flip side.
So basically the main
reason that I wanted to be
in this general area, I guess,
was just because I love Japanese music
and I have a bunch of, I
guess, Nakama, I suppose,
that I want to be close to.
- We are Nakama.
- Yeah and hang out with,
and then make music together
and just do fun stuff.
And I couldn't do that where I was before.
And now that I'm able to,
everything is so much better
and I instantly feel so much better
about existence and it's great.
And I hope that I can continue
chasing my dreams here
because when I first arrived,
it's like everything that
could go wrong, went wrong
and I was in a terrible
place, when I first came here.
- Did you get like the
culture shock of moving here?
- Yeah, definitely.
And not knowing, not knowing
any Japanese at all, et cetera,
having to figure out everything on my own
having no souls, no money.
- And you didn't have any
friends here or anything either?
- I did from the internet,
but I was not in...
I was not located in a place
where I could hang out with them, I guess.
So, yeah, it was just not great.
- We had a hard enough time moving here
when we want to know each other
and to have an agency helping us.
So I can't imagine how it was for you.
- It was something else
but you know, every...
I look at it this way, every single day,
I get a little bit closer
to being at the exact place
that I want to be, that I
thought of like three years ago,
when I set out to do all
this and that's progress.
Yeah.
- Yeah, absolutely.
Yeah 'cause nothing sucks
more than, you know,
working towards something
and then three years passes
and you're like, "Oh, I'm still here."
- Yeah, exactly.
- I mean, like I've heard
your Japanese in your streams
and it's definitely fine.
Like you definitely sound...
(babbles)
- I'm not saying you're like
super fluent or anything
but like it is definitely
ore than sufficient enough
to like get by here.
- It's much better than me.
- To get by, right?
- It's much better than these two.
- Well, thank you. That feels good know.
- You don't suck like us Cali.
- Yeah.
- As you said earlier--
- Your Japanese is good Cali.
- Thank you. Just really--
- Just don't suck.
- Just get good.
(laughs)
- Despite my really...
(speaks Japanese)
Like I really, really can't say things
in a way that is natural.
- I feel like that like adds
like a completely like different
type of cantle with that.
- That's what Kay's and Kiara were saying
when I was saying things strangely,
when we did our collab is
they were laughing so much.
And I said, "I'm saying things weird."
And they said, "No, it's cute."
Like it's funny. And I'm like, "Really?
"You don't think, it sounds like fucked up
"and like, it makes you
like, like me less."
They're like, "No."
- No, there's like a...
- There's like a weird, innocent story.
- Yeah, I think everyone
likes the other accent
where they struggle.
It's really endearing because
they're trying so hard--
- It's like in witnessing,
like a Japanese post and try
and speak to you in English.
Like you hear it and it's clearly broken,
but there's like a weird chantel.
I mean we have an entire
fucking genre of clips
where it's just VTubers
trying to speak English words.
- Those usually do like the best,
because it's just so
endearing that you look at it
and you're like, "Aw, man,
they're trying so hard.
"It's so fucking cute."
- When that dog said, I
love you, I felt that.
- Yes.
- The whole reason why like, you know,
Korone is English only
streams do so fucking well
is because it's literally
that for like two hours.
It's just clips galore.
So I think like in, you
know, in the opposite way,
like I think you're able
to achieve that as well
when you speak Japanese.
Like I'm sure Japanese people like,
"Oh man, like she's clearly trying."
But like the fact that
it's not exactly perfect
is what makes it endearing.
- Yeah. That's a good point actually.
- Yeah.
- Now that you say--
- Because I certainly don't
get that when I speak Japanese.
- Oh yeah.
(laughs)
- They're looking at me and they're like,
"Oh man he's trying his best."
It's more like, "Holy shit!
"Why?"
(laughs)
- Okay, Do you, when you're in Japan,
do people assume you're Japanese or?
- No.
- It's weird.
- This man looks Japanese.
- This man looks white.
- I look white as fuck.
- Yeah.
He looks white.
Are you kidding me.
- It's really weird, right,
because like, whenever I'm
walking with like say Aki,
she's usually the one that
gets approached in Japanese
because she looks more Asian than I do.
And then when the opposite effect happens
where she can't speak a word of Japanese
and yet I can is where like
the whole, like what happens.
I remember, like, when I used to intern
at like a tech agency
here, like during uni,
I used to be the guy who
had to like invite guests
in for like during business
meetings for that company.
So I was the one on the phone
organizing like the time and days
and you know, being like,
"Okay, I'll come down
"and, you know, get you
from the bottom floor.
"So, you know, bring you into the office."
And every time I did that,
I'm sure they were expecting, you know,
a super Japanese dude to
come down from the elevator.
But the moment they re the elevator opens
and they just see this white dude.
They're like,
"You're the guy, we just
talked on the phone."
And I'm like, "Yeah."
And they're like, "Okay, this is weird."
And it happened every fucing time.
- Yeah.
- Like, yeah. I never get used to it.
Especially every time someone
at the fucking gives me.
- All the time.
But what's interesting about that is that
when they say it to you,
that's how you know, it's not Josie.
- Congo. Josie was on the podcast.
- I don't think so.
Nihongo Josie just means
you're very good at Japanese.
Right. Basically.
- Which is basically
like what they say to every foreigner
who attempts to speak Japanese.
Like if you actually fluent
in Japanese, they weren't
going to Nihongo Josie.
- Yeah, exactly.
- Like it's only when it's like,
you know, your Japanese is like broken.
When you get the nigingo joke.
- It just feels like condescending.
- Exactly.
- Like, "Oh, nihongo josie."
- Let's see...
- It's like, all I said was.
(speaks japanese)
- Just the one word.
And they're like, Whoa.
- That's like, that's like,
if a Japanese person came up
to me and said, thank you.
You don't go.
(speaks Japanese)
- You ever ordering in
Japanese at a restaurant.
And then like, as you're talking
in Japanese, like to them,
they'll be like, "Oh,
here's the English menu."
And I'm like, yeah, but
I was just talking...
- And then you keep
talking to them in Japanese
and then they keep
talking to you in English.
- Yeah, exactly.
But the way that I try to think about it,
somebody said it really well before to me
when I was kind of like, "I
wish that they would stop."
What someone said to me was,
"Well, it's not, about you.
"It's about them."
You know?
They want to be polite I guess.
And it's just their
sense of like, you know,
like being kind and polite to you.
It's more about, about
them and not about you.
So try and think of it
that way kind of thing.
- I just complain about everything.
So I can have a successful
heart operation.
I'd be like, "Bloody
hell, it took a long time,
"didn't it?"
- Then like in new hunger, Josie is like,
when I get this all the time,
because like they always ask.
(speaks foreign language)
- Right.
- And of course I say like, yeah,
(speaks Japanese)
And they're like, "Oh, okay."
English menu.
- It's never going to matter.
- I had the NHA guy
which is basically like
the TV license guy.
- The television man.
- You should be paying a television--
- Is he the other death reaper.
- Yes the other one I'm
acquainted with him.
- Yeah.
- Came to my door and he
was like, he looked at me,
he just stared at me, like oh,
when I opened the door
and he was like, "Oh."
(speaks Japanese)
And I was like,
I saw the NHK thing in his
hand and I'm like, well,
(speaks Japanese)
He was like, no, no.
- So explain the NHK guy
is like, NHK is like...
NHK the it's like...
There's no cable.
- And basically the NHK guy
comes. And like you usually,
if you own a TV in your house,
you have to pay like a feat.
- Like a license.
- Like if you use the TV.
- If you have like a kind of
like a TV connection, right?
- Yeah. If you have a TV connection.
Yeah. That's the...
A lot of people just own
a TV because you know,
the user for things like
streaming or like for games,
like not to actually watch Japanese TV,
but the NHK guy doesn't give a fuck.
He's like, if you weren't a
TV, you have to pay the fee.
- Yes. It's actually the law, apparently.
- It is the law apparently.
But like a lot of it is also
just like a waste of money to
just be like,
I'm not going to pay a fee
for something I don't use.
- I actually can't get the TV.
Cause you have to use a card.
I don't have the card.
- It's like the NHK color.
- I don't have it.
- And yet they're just
so persistent to like,
get you to pay that fee
for something that you don't even use.
It's like, no, you have to understand.
I don't use the TV to watch NHK or right.
Like I'm a millennial.
I use it for other things like
gaming stream and streaming.
- You can't run away
because even if you don't speak Japanese,
they will pull out Google
translate so have fun.
I felt like I had to be
careful mentioning them
because I was doing a
play through of a game.
And there was this
character that reminded me
of the NHK man and I just had to keep it.
I had to keep it's a...
(laughs)
- The NHK man special appearance in DOOM.
Nah, that it was a game called Mad Father.
And there's this guy that goes--
Yeah, I did.
It's a three-part series. Yeah.
- That's all right. Yeah.
I remember you were saying
in your debut stream
that you love RPG making games, right?
- Yes. Just the most old,
just wretched like old ass pixel art.
- I played so many of those
when I was doing lets play it.
- Like mad father, dude,
I remember watching all of that.
Like Peter Park, there was
someone played for all of it.
- And what is his game?
Just to explain to me.
- Mad Father or you know, RPG maker game.
So mad father is this one...
It's created by.
Is it created by Japanese guy.
- Yes.
I think Sen is.
- Yeah.
- He's the guy who also did...
Oh my God.
What was the...
- But basically mad father
is all about this girl
who has a crazy dad.
- That dad is mad.
- And basically like, she's
like leaves in this...
It's been so long since I play the game.
But like,
- I can't remember what happened.
- Cali can you explain it?
Cause you probably played it the most--.
- Yeah, sure.
So there's this girl and
she lives in a mansion
with her mad dad and he does
weird stuff in the basement.
And you know that from the beginning.
But basically...
- Where is this going?
- It's a ride.
So basically
her mother has died
and the game starts off
by you get these flashbacks
and you see your life
and you realize that
she's kind of like alone
in this mentioned with her fucked up dad
and his mistress and
they're doing weird stuff
in the basement.
That isn't just what
you think is going on.
There's other stuff happening too.
- It gets pretty fucked up.
- And so she hears like
screams from the basement
and turns out there's
a curse on the house.
That's based on like some bullshit
with like her mother is
angry or something like that.
Maybe that's a spoiler.
Maybe we should cut that.
- It's too late games.
- The games like how old is this?
- It's a really old game.
So basically, yeah,
there's a curse in the house.
And all these like bodies
start coming to life,
reanimated, corpses and whatever.
It's basically like your
classic RPG maker, horror game.
It's got like jump scares
and puzzles and story.
And it's super fun and super crazy.
But there are also some scuff parts
that I just love about it.
It's just classic old RPG maker game.
For example, when you're
mad dad is like chasing you
with his chainsaw whenever
he comes after you.
And it's the jump scare when he gets you.
That the image just zooms
in so far and the pixels,
that's the scary part about it.
How many pixels make up dad?
It's not a high number.
That's that's the funniest.
- That what I love about
RPG like horror games though
is that like every single one
like, no matter how scary
the jump scares might be,
there's just something
really campy about it.
That you just can't help, but laugh at.
- You're being scare by pixels.
- Yeah.
Yeah.
- What's the one RPG maker game.
I think To The Moon or something.
I really fucking loved that
one. I was crying like a baby.
Watching fucking Pewdie pie
play when I was like 15, so sad.
And I've watched the story, Joey.
- Wow. Yeah.
I was about to say, I was like,
that is like a hundred percent story.
- Yeah.
- I actually think I
enjoy this game story.
- It's fun when he's
watching someone else play.
- I genuinely think I like game stories
when I watch someone else play it.
But when it's me playing it, I'm like...
- You want that game play, man.
Just that straight game play.
- Reap and tear, man
- Yeah. Reap and tear until it is done.
- There's also the...
There was a sequel to that as well.
- Yeah. There was.
- Much later.
- Yeah. I actually liked it
more than the first I believe.
- Really?
- Yeah. I liked the...
There's like a twist that's really good.
And the plot is just, it hits
some like relatable spots.
- It hits different there you go.
- To the moon.
Like I remember I played
that on my channel
when I was doing let's plays
and like, it's the music man.
The music is just fucking
kills me, its so good.
And it's all done by one dude.
It's crazy to think about.
- Like the entire game?
- This guy who did the story,
the art, the everything
was just all done by one dude.
Like he had help with like
the music, like composition.
He wrote it all and just
got someone else to like,
do the composition for it.
But he did the story.
He did all the, like the
programming and everything.
It's just...
- I love that kind of stuff.
Just like one dude just
making a whole freaking game.
- I mean, like Colps
party as well was made
by like three people.
- Yeah.
- I wish I was that talented.
- I know.
- It takes a lot of passion.
- Why am I so lazy.
- Like Touhou was made by one dude.
- All I know what to do is how
to talk about anime titties.
- Yep.
- My job--
- That can be a talent.
I sure can't do that.
- It's not a talent.
- I can't even do that on
my own. I have an editor.
- I can't even put a
PC together on my own.
- Your PC was like, literally that meme
of like unlock your brain.
- Yeah exactly.
- But what if we use more
than 10% of our brain?
- So like what would you say then
is your favorite RPG maker game?
- Gosh, there are so many.
Let me name off some
ones that I really like.
I really like Wadanohara.
Have you guys played Wadanohara?
- Is that the guy, right?
- Yeah. That's right.
And then he made some other really up game
called like Mogeko Castle.
Yeah.
That gave me some freaking a
nightmares. I tell you what?
I really like The Crooked Man series.
Do you guys ever play those?
- Yeah. I think I played
almost every RPG horror games.
- Oh, seriously?
Nice.
- No, 'cause I used to
play them like exclusively
on my channel
'cause I got really
massive off the Corpse.
- Oh yeah Corpse Party.
- So naturally I had to
go into the RPG maker.
- Well, the first one that
I ever played was Eve,
I feel like that's like a
first for a lot of people.
A first for a lot of people.
- I know some of these
'cause Sydney loves these
kinds of like RPG, horror games
as well.
So that's why I know some of these.
- Eve is probably like
the most famous one.
- Yeah. And it's old.
Like super old.
And then I feel like a lot of people
also know Witch's House as well.
It's like a classic, like jump scare one.
I need to play that on stream.
I feel like everyone would really enjoy.
- Pocket mirror is also a really good.
- Oh yeah. That's a good one too.
I recently played that.
- We could get out of the
room and leave you two.
- All you have to do there,
is someone who translates
a lot of RPG maker games.
And I recommend, of course,
obviously you buy the games of course.
But for those that it is impossible to do.
The translated patches are
available and they're very easy
to access in one spot.
- They're really good too.
They're really good translations.
Like just someone who's just
talented and has the time
to just be like, "Oh yeah.
"Five hour game where it's
like exclusively talking.
"Yeah. I'm a finnish translate that."
- Shout out to the translators again man.
- I got so into RPG maker games though,
that it got to a point where
after I played all of them,
I went onto the RPG maker forums
and just started downloading
people's like projects
that they were working
on and playing them.
- Oh wow.
- And that was something.
Let me tell you what.
- Were any of them like memorable?
- I mean, by how not great.
(laughs)
That makes me sound like such a dick.
Hold on a sec.
- Why try when you're not good?
- Just get good.
Just don't be bad.
- I gotta laugh at them.
And getting a laugh.
Hey, listen, man, that
serotonin release for one laugh.
Okay, good, fine.
Be proud of yourself
for that. I felt good.
Like the laugh at you.
Hey listen (laughs) man.
No, I had some fun times.
I remember some real janky ones.
I don't know if this
was someone's project,
but there's this super
like obscure ass one
called what is like Desert
Nightmare or something.
And I think...
- That sounds like an indie game.
- I think I got it off the forum
and it's like you're this
chick and you get out the car,
your car is broken down
and you're in a desert
and it's a horror story.
And I remember it was so freaking jank,
but I played it all the way
til the end three hours.
Someone's just project on
the RPG maker game forums.
So I got invested. It was
shitty but I got invested, man.
(laughs)
Yeah. I remember that.
It was good.
- Is this a compliment.
- No,
whoever made that game.
Good on you. I know you're
out there somewhere.
You might see this, you might not,
but fuck yeah, man.
- There might be a Cali
simp, you never know.
- Oh geez.
Don't take it as an insult.
I genuinely had a lot
of fun with that game.
- Like the next to the next
red soup chat you get is like,
"Hi, I'm the developer for like--"
- Oh.
(laughs)
Hold on. Wait.
Maybe I'm joking.
- I cannot imagine going on a forum
looking for shitty games.
- I was desperate, man.
You get desperate sometimes
after you go through all that stuff
and you're like, I want
more, I need my fix.
- It's like, you're doing that.
The me just doing super high.
Cause he gone for like the millionth time
trying beat the hardest level.
Have you seen super hexagon.
- Yeah, of course.
- I fucking love that game.
- What is that?
- It's like a visual crack game.
It's hard.
- It's like epilepsy. The game basically.
- Is it like a puzzle game?
- It's on screen right now.
It's it's very difficult,
but I love it.
I'll show you.
- [Joey] That's the rhythm.
It's like, not the rhythm game,
but it's like a...
How do you explain a games like that?
- [Connor] Its fucking seizure games.
- [Joey] Survival game?.
- [Connor] Survival seizure.
- [Cali] That sounds
kinda fun.
- [Connor] Have you played that game
where you jumped the block.
- Yeah.
- Was it Geometry Dash?
Geometry Dash, is hat the one?
- Geometry Dash
It's kind of like the same
kind of genre, I'd say
where it's like you'll pick the level over
and over a hundred thousand at the time.
- I remember the only one game I remember,
it was called like the
impossible game or something.
I don't remember where
you to jump this like...
- That's it.
- Is it called geometry dash.
- Wow I think they rebranded.
some of the charts where
he's screaming right now
is a geometry dash pro.
- I just remember the music was so good
and I wanted to complete it
just so I can hear the track
all the way to the end.
- Yes.
- I completed one stage,
the easiest stage.
- We're gonna get a blue super champion.
Like, "Hi, I'm the developer.
"You've got it all wrong."
- What's like the weirdest,
super chat you've ever gotten?
Or is there, is there any
that stand out in your mind?
- There's some pretty
fun ones. For example,
there's a reoccurring character
in my stream called...
Am I allowed to...
We actually never got that checked, huh?
If ghost writer, right.
Ghost writer outside my house,
there is a fricking
skeleton on a motorcycle
that just every day when I'm streaming
five times a stream just
outside of my window,
just, and it gets on my last damn there.
Well, everyone's, everyone's
called him ghost writer.
Right. And he appears sometimes
in the super Chet to say,
sorry for being loud outside
or whatever, that kind of.
And I'm like, thanks
for your super chat man.
But that doesn't change. The
fact I'm at you right now, man.
- Maybe they're trying
to use accurate location
to determine your pinpoint address.
How far away
- I know that it's this type of,
- Oh, for sure.
I believe it.
- It's like the news,
you know, of like how,
like someone found that Japanese
idol because of like, your.
- I read about that.
- I mean, you don't have to worry about it
because you know why we're not
wearing sunglasses right now.
It's just like, I'm not going to lay down.
- Be careful, be careful.
- But I guess like,
for those of, you know,
for people of trash tastes
who don't know anything about
you, like, do you want to
like shout out your stuff?
- Yeah, sure.
Come check out my, my streams anytime.
So basically I stream, well,
it really depends on the
week and what's going on.
I'm busy right now. But by
the time that this comes out,
things should be back to normal.
So I usually stream maybe
five or six times a week.
It depends on what's going on with me.
But I try to take two
days, two day breaks.
And then sometimes I stream twice a day.
My time zones are a little
are a little weird, right.
But I try to stream,
I guess it's morning time in
America and either afternoon or
evening in Japan. And
then on the weekends,
it'll be afternoons mornings
in Japan and evenings afternoon
ish in America. So come check them out.
And I also do music. I have
a playlist in my YouTube,
just look up Maury
Calliope or Calliope Maury.
Or you can even just look up
Maury channel, Maury, Maury,
hololive.
And you should find me
immediately and come hang out,
subscribe. If you like my stuff,
if you don't, that's cool.
You don't got to do that either.
You don't have to.
- Don't forget to like and subscribe.
- Self-confidence.
- If you don't want to, you don't have to,
but my stuff isn't for everyone.
Do it then please.
- But yeah. Well Lisa,
I searched chat energy.
Exactly. But yeah, we'll leave that.
We'll leave the links down
in the description as always.
- Thank you. Yeah.
If you like an interesting rap,
I guess pop rap Japanese
rap inspired English rap.
I don't know.
- Let's see anime girl, spit bars.
Check out fire, man.
Good.
- I hope you'll enjoy them. Actually.
They're available. I'm
on some music stores now.
I believe definitely
Apple music worldwide.
For sure.
Check it out.
Spotify. Maybe.
I don't know. By the time this comes out,
who can say maybe go check just in case.
- We'll see. We'll see.
But yeah,
I think that's everything I
wanted to talk about today.
This has been the most
interesting this episode.
I've trashed taste.
This has been a venture
for all of us. I would say.
Did you?
Yeah.
Thank you very much for joining
us today and being our very
first 2d guests.
I feel bad that I haven't watched any,
any of your stuff before this,
but I certainly will
fix that a lot though.
At least charming personality.
- Thank you. I appreciate that.
Come watch me really
suck at doom if you want,
but listen to me.
Oh, thank you.
I appreciate it. Yeah.
You're terrible at this. Thanks.
I know.
- But.
- Hey also, let's give a
shout out to our lovely,
lovely patrons who are
on the screen right now.
Who's your favorite patron? Kelly.
- Oh gosh. Let me go ahead and look.
- What do you mean?
Like to support the show is
always a good way of patron.
Also follow us on Twitter in
subreddits. Send all the I'm.
Sure you'll this'll be spammed with.
- Kelly beams.
- I'm secretly happy that now,
like the holler live memes
and our sub Reddit would now
finally merge together. Exactly.
And we can shove all of these
VT with memes and find the
corners face and be like, huh?
This seems.
- Time for me to start
modding the celebrator.
I'm kidding. I'm kidding.
But yeah, guys so much for joining us.
We'd love to have you back if you want.
We got the cool.
Yeah, of course, of course,
because you've said it now,
so it has to happen.
We're waiting.
I anticipate it.
We gotta, we gotta do a premiere
so we can have super chat.
We can still do it. Oh my God.
Premiere the video and
there'll be a super chat.
Thanks so much again.
Finally, we're going to go.
- Money. Thank you very much
for watching trash day today.
We will see you next time.